i de quatre membres du conseil
scientifique messieurs simon cauchemez
daniel benamouzig madame marie allaitent
grare et denimal vie ainsi que madame
caroline jégu chargé de mission mise en
place le 11 mars 2020 le conseil
scientifique a été consacrée par la loi
du 23 mars 2020 qui en a fait un des
éléments de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
l'article l 31 31-19 du code de la santé
publique prévoit ainsi en cas de
déclaration de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
il est réunie sans délai un comité de
scientifiques
son président est nommé par décret du
président de la république
ce comité comprend deux personnalités et
qualifiés respectivement nommés par le
président de l'assemblée nationale et le
président du sénat ainsi que des
personnalités qualifiées nommées par
décret le comité rang périodiquement des
avis sur l'état de la catastrophe
sanitaire
les connaissances scientifiques qui s'y
rapportent et les mesures propres à y
mette un terme y compris celles relevant
de différents articles ainsi que sur la
durée de leurs applications
ces avis seront rendues publiques sans
délai
le comité 10 ou lorsque prend fin l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
le conseil a rendu des avis public à
chacune des étapes de la gestion de la
crise avant ou après les annonces du
gouvernement
il est pluridisciplinaire et notre
commission denquête a déjà entendu
quelques uns de ses membres sur
différentes thématiques c'était le cas
d'arnaud fonds année dans le cadre de la
table ronde consacrée à la gestion de la
crise sanitaire dans l'oise mais aussi
la semaine dernière bruno lina
sur la question des tests et du
dépistage
elle nous entendrons cet après-midi
d'ailleurs yazdan yazdanpanah sur les
questions de la recherche et des
traitements sur ces derniers ce sp1
ce goût comité le comité analyse
recherche et expertises dirigée par
françoise barré sinoussi a été mise en
place
il est chargé de faire des
recommandations sur la recherche ainsi
que sur des essais cliniques et
thérapeutiques professeur vous avez été
entendu à deux reprises par la
commission denquête de l'assemblée
nationale ce qui me permet de faire écho
aux propos que vous avez tenus devant
nos collègues députés
nous sommes en effet aujourd'hui dans
une logique de retour d'expérience sur
la gestion de crise et vous avez déclaré
en conclusion le 18 juin dernier que
vous aviez deux messages à faire passer
premièrement il faut anticiper pour
mieux préparer
deuxièmement je pense que nous devons
avoir une vraie réflexion sur la
construction et sur l'avenir de la santé
publique en france
avez vous dit pourriez vous développer
et précisé ses deux points ce matin
enfin vous avez déclaré à l'assemblée
nationale que le conseil scientifique
avait fait entendre je cite sa petite
musique
pour notre part comme nombre de nos
concitoyens nous avons plutôt eu le
sentiment d'entendre parfois une
assourdissante cacophonie de la part du
monde scientifique
comment l'expliquez ou chez un
professeur je vais vous demander de
présenter vos brièvement vos principaux
messages 10e 15 minutes maximum afin de
laisser bien sûr le temps où s'échangent
et les personnes qui vous accompagnent
pour un répondre bien sûr aux questions
après avoir prêté serment car nous
sommes dans une commission d' enquête et
il vous faut il faut rappeler que tout
témoignage mensonger susceptibles d'être
puni d'une amende importante 75000 euros
ou d'une paix et d'une peine de prison
pouvant aller jusque 5 ans ceci dit je
vais vous demander de prêter serment de
dire la vérité toute la vérité de lever
la main droite et dire je le jure
professeur delfraissy oui je prête
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité je le jure simon cauchemez aise
daniel benamouzig je jure madame marie à
l'aide car caroline jaeggy denimal vie
merci je vous rappelle bien sûr que le
port du masque est obligatoire et sans
plus tarder je vous passe la parole cher
professeur beaucoup bonjour à tous
juste peut-être une précision caroline
est une jeune sciences po qui nous
accompagnent comme chargé de mission
donc elle est un peu en dehors de vous
l'avez fait jurer c'est très bien
puisqu'elle est là mais elle est un peu
en dehors quand même du conseil
scientifique véritable je rappelle que
c'est la deuxième d'ailleurs stagiaires
de sciences po et que c'est à peu près
les moyens dont nous avons eu depuis le
début de cette crise c'est à dire une
stagiaire de sciences po pour nous aider
alors juste peut-être en introduction
les kikis sommes-nous vous l'avez vous
l'avez rappelé donc je vais passer très
rapidement les dates aussi une des
questions qui est parfois posé sur qui
sommes nous c'est pourquoi finalement
nous n'avions pas sale comité
multidisciplinaire et pourquoi nous
n'avions pas d'économistes dans le dans
le dans le comité dès le départ j'avais
souhaité qu'il y ait des membres de
sciences humaines et sociales qui un
représentant de d'associations de la
société civile économie si on en avait
discuté je vous rappelle que c'était le
début de la crise et que le sanitaire
était à l'époque très largement dominant
mais néanmoins s'est très vite intéressé
à cet aspect des conséquences
économiques on a travaillé d'ailleurs
avec des groupes d'experts économiques
mais il nous apparaît que ce n'était pas
pertinent de l'avoir au sein d'un groupe
calais comme essentiellement une vision
scientifique et médicale ce d'autant que
le gouvernement avait par ailleurs lancé
un groupe d'experts économistes ont que
c'est une question qui a été posée je
vous donne des éléments de réponse
vous l'avez rappelé mais dans le
contexte actuel je préfère insister sur
ce point
ce comité est fait pour éclairer le
gouvernement et les autorités sanitaires
en aucune façon en effet pour décider je
vois de ça et là et ça revient là en ce
moment après une période si c'était déjà
arrivé dans la période du mois de juin
un troisième pouvoir médical bullshit en
oublie c'est uniquement dans les médias
il n'y a absolument pas de troisième
pouvoir médical
on est dans une grande démocratie en
france il ya vous est on est on passe
devant une commission du sénat on est
passé devant les commissions de
l'assemblée nationale les experts
scientifiques et médicaux sont là pour
aider à des décisions difficiles
difficile à prendre parce qu'elles sont
compliquées j'ai peut être dans le mot
difficile va dire qu'elles sont
difficiles en soit le deuxième élément
sur comment nous avons travaillé
alors si je suis venu avec un certain
nombre de membres du comité scientifique
c'est parce que c'est c'est vraiment un
travail de groupe
c'est un exercice d'intelligence
collective ce n'est pas du tout je
dirais un homme seul
même si évidemment le président est mis
en avant pour des raisons diverses et
variées tant mieux d'ailleurs n'est là
pour j'ai les épaules pour recevoir les
coups mais ce sont des décisions qui
sont collégiales et qui sont de
construction entre guillemets qui
aboutissent on arrive avec des idées
différentes et on construit de façon
collégiale
cet avis on a souhaité
et c'est nous qui l'avons souhaité que
le on ait des avis écrit que ces avis
écrits soient rendus publics
avec un certain décalage entre ce qui
est annonce ce qui est donné au
gouvernement
et ce qui est mis public et c'est ça ma
part essentiel en termes de en termes de
vision démocratique ce conte ce sur quoi
on s'appuie puissent être partagés avec
avec nos concitoyens
c'est d'ailleurs un mode de travail
habituel en médecine ces essais je veux
dire la décision maintenant est de moins
en moins celle d'un homme ou d'une femme
est de plus en plus celle de groupe et
les rcp en médecine sont faits pour
avoir des décisions collégiales et donc
on est vraiment dans une vision
habituelle
on a dit ce comité scientifique est
quelque chose de très nouveau
j'y reviendrai mais il est finalement sa
décision le mode de travailler et est
habituel alors on a eu que quatre grands
moments le premier si je me si j'essaie
de résumer pour tirer un peu des leçons
le premier évidemment dans la première
période
comment faire comprendre politique entre
guillemets qu'une dans cette période
très difficile 20 du 10 12 14 15 mars
jusqu'au 17 mars pour aboutir à une
décision de confinement d'un pays
je rappelle au passage que c'est pas une
décision seulement française mais vous
savez elle est allée dans tous les
grands pays européens et qu'ensuite on
peut discuter du moment exact de la
prise de décision autour du confinement
généralisée donc ça c'est nos premiers
avis ensuite on a eu d'une ce deuxième
période qui était comment gérer le
confinement et avec une série d'avis
autour de ça une troisième période qui a
porté autour du déconfinement qu'elle
était et là on a commencé à quitter les
aspects je dirais de conseils immédiat
pour rentrer dans une vision de
stratégie autour de commandes construit
comment quels sont les besoins les pré
requis pour le déconfinement et on a
beaucoup travaillé à l'époque avec le
groupe castex la banque jean castex
devienne premier ministre
comme vous le savez il s'était occupé de
cette pièce de déconfinement et puis on
a une 4e quatrième période qui est
autour d'eux
qui est autour finalement de deux avis
stratégiques autour du déconfinement
ensuite de quel scénario à venir au
moment du des confirmands quelle place
pour les plans de préparation et de
celle de l'encens des des structures et
en particulier de que l'état ne
s'endorment pas pendant et que les
différents corps de l'état ne sont
dormais pas pendant l'été
et puis dans notre avis numéro 8 de fin
juillet comme anticipé la rentrée et on
a posé sur la table le problème des 20
grandes métropoles françaises qui à nos
yeux était un enjeu majeur pour la
rentrée plutôt d'ailleurs que les
régions c'est à l'intérieur des régions
ce sont bien les métropoles qui sont qui
sont un des points d'un des points
d'attention parce que c'est là où se
joue la densité de personnes le travail
les transports et et évidemment les des
personnes les plus jeunes
juste un troisième point sur les parce
que vous l'avez poser dans les dents les
questions que vous nous avez adressé les
relations avec les différentes agences
qui existent au niveau français bon
vraiment dans d'emblée moi j'ai souhaité
qu' on ne craint que cet objet nouveau
qu'était le le conseil scientifique qui
a été créée comme vous l'avez rappelé
par la loi mais qui pendant quelques
dizaines de jours était au milieu de
nulle part puisque la loi n'avait pas
encore été voté j'ai souhaité d'emblée
que ça soit pas rajouter une couche
comme on a l'habitude en france de deux
structures décisionnelles et donc on
s'appuie sur ce qui existait déjà et on
a eu des relations bien sûr avec santé
publique france le haut comité de santé
publique santé publique france la
directrice de santé publique france
était avec nous à l'elysée lors de la
réunion du 12 12 mars
j'ai fait rentrer le président du haut
comité de santé publique comme membre à
part entière du comité scientifique
nous avons eu des relations et clash s
avec la recherche avec reacting éveil
est en liesse dans la foule on parlera
cet après midi je suis à l'origine de
dans une vie antérieure de la
construction de réacteurs sur comme un
modèle de construction et de réponse
aux épidémies d'urgence on a eu beaucoup
de relations avec la rsm avec le comité
national d'éthique aux passagers je n'ai
pas démissionné de la présidence du
comité national d'éthique mais je me
suis mis en déport parce que je jugeais
immédiatement que c'était incompatible à
la fois d'être très opérationnelles dans
une certaine mesure avec la présidence
du comité scientifique et de poursuivre
mon action au niveau du du ccn et donc
c'est la vice présidente qui a pris qui
a pris ma place et ensuite avec bien sûr
la cnil on a fait un gros effort pendant
le mois de avril
papa mars parce qu'on n'est pas le temps
été complètement ensevelis
pour aussi avoir des liens avec les
académies l'académie de médecine
l'académie des sciences le cnrs avec les
grandes structures pour leur expliquer
ce qu'on savait pour comprenez je dirais
on prenait telle direction quels étaient
les enjeux qui pouvait se poser de créer
du lien avec avec l'ensemble et puis
enfin avec un résultat plus ou moins bon
je vous la corde on a
et créer du lien avec nos collègues
étrangers puisque vous savez qu'il
existe un certain nombre de comités
scientifiques
pas tout à fait identiques aux nôtres à
l'étranger en angleterre en italie en
allemagne et donc on a créé du lien mais
vous savez que on a eu des discussions
d'ordre scientifique des changes mais
finalement que l'europe à cette occasion
ne sait pas très bien construite disons
le puisque finalement l'ensemble des
décisions qui ont été prises par les
autorités sanitaires des différents pays
s'est construite au niveau de chaque
pays chacun a eu tendance à se refermer
sur soi même pour des raisons sur
lesquelles si vous voulez on pourra
revenir alors le quatrième point c'est
c'est la relation avec le politique on
peut se dire ensemble que c'est une
crise sans précédent
moi je l'avais évoqué lors d'un bon
niveau quand qu'on aurait une mutation
d'un virus grippal et non pas un cornac
virus et à vrai dire j'y croyais et à
vrai dire j'y croyais sans y croire mais
c'est une crise sans précédent et donc
les les relations entre l'installation
d'un comité scientifique et qui est
installée par le politique
d'une certaine façon et le comité
scientifique pose deux ou trois
questions sur lesquelles j'aurais
revenir la première c'est l'autonomie de
ce comité scientifique est ce que nous
sommes autonomes ou est-ce que nous
sommes dépendants du politique et la
réponse on a tout fait en tout cas pour
garder notre indépendance dans à la fois
dans notre mode de fonctionnement
je vous rappelle qu'on peut être saisie
par le gouvernement mais qu'on peut
s'autosaisir qu'on a joué la
transparence et et que on a été amené à
avoir des propositions qui n'ont pas été
retenu par par le gouvernement pourra y
revenir
le deuxième le deuxième élément c'est
que dans ce comité scientifique on a des
médecins et des scientifiques et donc
avec un modèle qui n'est pas qui dans le
modèle de la hiérarchie de la haute
administration française
nous ne sommes pas les énarques nous ne
sommes pas des hauts fonctionnaires qui
doivent répondre je dirais dans le
contexte français au à l'ordre politique
nous mêmes nous sommes des médecins et
scientifiques donc sans sans relation
hiérarchique par rapport il compris au
plus haut niveau de l'état et donc avec
une
re libre et une grande facilité de
parole en tout cas ça moi ça ne m'a pas
du tout gêné par contre il ya des enjeux
qui sont qui sont qui reste fondamentaux
dans la relation entre entre un comité
scientifique et le politique au plus
haut niveau
premièrement la science se construit sur
les incertitudes et s'il n'ya pas
d'incertitude en sciences et bien on ne
construit pas de la bonne science et
donc on a deux pas en avant un pas en
arrière vous avez vu qu'on a il ya des
hésitations je comprends que certains
d'entre vous puisse nous interrogé
ensuite sur les différents mouvements ou
prises de paroles des scientifiques
distinguons ce qu'est la prise de parole
des scientifiques et la prise de parole
du comité scientifique de ces deux
choses qui sont qui sont différentes et
on vous parlera tout à l'heure de
l'absence de régulation à cet égard mais
cette notion d'incertitude
elle ne plaît pas aux politiques par
définition qui a besoin évidemment
d'avoir quelque chose qui se construit
je dirais avec une certaine forme de
deux certitudes à court terme le 10ème
temps le deuxième élément c'est le temps
le temps des médias il est quelques
heures maintenant le temps du politique
il est quelques jours et le temps de la
science c'est plusieurs semaines ou
plusieurs mois et je les dis d'emblée
que nous n'aurions pas de résultats des
essais thérapeutiques de construction
solide avant trois ou quatre points et
on comprend bien que c'est difficile à
qu'on a intégré pour pour un décideur
politique de se dire qu'il n'aura pas de
réponse scientifique solide avant trois
ou quatre mois et le reste il faut
oublier c'est à dire que ceux qui
pensent qu'on peut avoir une résultat
résultat extrêmement rapide et bien se
trompe si on veut des résultats solides
la science monde prend un peu de temps
et enfin très très clairement et je le
répète à obtient un moment sur à la fois
de ma part et de la part du 10 des
ventes du comité scientifique
on a eu l ébauche du début de
commencement d'une idée qui avait un
troisième pouvoir médical qui était en
train de s'installer en france
oublions ça nous étions là pour éclairer
sur des sur des questions difficiles et
on le reste et on le voit que c'est
d'actualité mais c'est bien le politique
qui décide
alors après tout ça la relation avec les
autorités et au plus haut niveau de
l'état s'est fait de notre point de vue
dans un climat de confiance et dans un
climat qui s'est globalement bien
déroulé avec des relations bien sûr avec
des différents conseillers de matignon
de l'elysée du ministère de la santé
sous forme de note sous forme d'avis
comme je l'aï indiqué et puis avec
parfois des positions divergentes
on a eu des positions divergentes au
moment de l'ouverture des écoles on a
une position divergente sur la place du
citoyen et la place de la société civile
et on pourra y revenir et qui va
paraître particulièrement importante
dans le contexte actuel où il n'y a pas
été mis en place de comités citoyens
tant au niveau national et on pourrait
peut-être l'envisagé la maintenant au
niveau des territoires
on a eu des positions aussi un moment
donné qu'ils étaient pour le moins
nuancé sur la sur l'aspect de la
gouvernance et avec eux on regrettait
une certaine forme de gouvernance ne se
soit ne se soient pas installées alors
dernier point peut-être pour sur le
conseil scientifique lui-même puis après
vous pour aller plus loin sur certaines
questions spécifiques
ce que nous ne sommes pas nous ne sommes
pas une instance de décision
nous ne décidons rien c'est bien le
politique qui décide
on est là pour l'éclairer je pense qu'il
faut être vraiment très très clairs là
dessus parce que je revois le débat
partir c'est un truc de médias et c'est
pas un truc de gens sérieux deuxièmement
on a nous ne sommes pas une agence une
structure pérenne nous ne sommes pas une
nouvelle agence sanitaire
c'est un comité qui est liée à la crise
sanitaire
il faut qu'il ait un début il faut qu'il
ait une fin et je vous rappelle que le
comité scientifique avait souhaité
disparaître et s'arrêter le 9 juillet
2020 que c'est vous messieurs mesdames
nous mesdames messieurs les sénateurs à
sa compagne est d'ailleurs par
l'assemblée nationale qui avait demandé
est ce que ce conseil scientifique soit
renouvelée jusqu'au 30 octobre
ce qui nous a mis
dans un je dirais dans un questionnement
de quelques jours autour du 14 juillet
on était renouvelé jusqu'au 30 octobre
on n'allait pas il fallait assumer je
dirais un d'après toussaint conseil
scientifique
on aurait pu imaginer aussi qu'on passe
la main à d'autres scientifiques c'est
pas ce forcément sur le conseil
scientifique et il nous a jugés en notre
âme et conscience et en tant que citoyen
qu'il était difficile de ne pas
accompagner en particulier dans cette
période d'été et surtout de rentrer nous
avions quand même anticipé des retours
du virus pour des raisons diverses et
variées sur lequel on pourra revenir et
qu'il était de notre devoir en tout cas
de rester puisque vous l'aviez demandé
jusqu'au 30 octobre
mais c'est une question de fond c'est à
dire qu'à partir du moment où on crée un
objet nouveau de ce type et qu'on lui
confie je le sens bien
finalement une sorte ou qu'on croit lui
confier une sorte de pouvoir qu'il n'a
pas qu'il n'a absolument pas puisque
c'est le c'est le politique qui décide
mais la meilleure façon d'y répondre
on le crée et on le termine et on est
totalement persuadé de sa après c'est en
fonction de la crise sanitaire à quel
moment alors sur les le deuxième élément
qu'on nous ne sommes pas assez on a on
n'était pas opérationnel c'est à dire
que on est là pour eux guidez construire
une doctrine construire une
une philosophie de la réponse vis-à-vis
d'eux et s'appuyant sur des bases
scientifiques autant que faire se peut
et je vous rappelle que la science a
évolué durant 7 2 ans cette crise on est
il ya plusieurs exemples sur lequel je
pourrai revenir mais c'est la science
évolue et donc comment construites ont
finalement quand on a une science qui
n'est pas si solide que ça et qu'on
découvre en marchant alors on a fait et
vous l'avez bien compris
nous avons été finalement une instance
de santé publique
l'innovation thérapeutique et très peu
arriver jusqu'à maintenant la médecine
telle que vous la connaissez cette
médecine qui s'appuie sur sur
l'innovation
elle est très peu arrivent et elle va
arriver mais elle est très peu arrivent
et les décisions que nous avons été
amenés à à à construire et à faire
prendre entre guillemets quand il l'a
souhaité par le politique au plus haut
niveau
et bien c'est essentiellement des
décisions de santé publique et on
revient à ce que j'avais indiqué à
l'assemblée nationale comment ce comité
a fait finalement à jouer un rôle de
construction de la pensée et de
décisions de santé publique en france à
l'heure même on peut s'interroger en
effet sur qu'est ce qui manque au niveau
français en termes d'outils et de
construction d'une vision de santé
publique et c'est quand même des grandes
leçons qui doivent sortir autour de ça
écoutez je crois que j'ai terminé parce
que ce sommet pour vous donner quelques
quelques points sur l'évolution des
connaissances et jeu une fois de plus je
comprends très bien les questionnements
qui se pose de la part à la fois de nos
concitoyens et de vous-même en disant
mais dans le fond on entend tout et son
contraire de la part d'un certain nombre
de personnalités scientifiques
alors d'abord séparons bien ce qui est
le comité scientifique qui prend la
parole ou led pro l'ont pas remarqué
mais au moment où nous sortons des avis
c'est à dire qu'on s'appuie sur ce que
nous venons de construire ou la pensée
c'est s'est écrite
c'est avec une vraie réflexion autour de
ce tas et puis ce barnum un peu
médiatique qui existe depuis maintenant
mi-avril qui s'étaient calmées un peu
pendant l'été qui reprend là depuis
trois semaines et où monsieur duchmol
madame x etc se croient tout savoir et c
est prendre la parole sur les médias je
le regrette daniel benamouzig vous dira
qu'il ya et vous peuvent approfondir sa
en disant qu'on a une absence de
régulation tour de ça et nous avons
essayé de d'essayer autant que faire se
peut de cadrer les choses mais c'est
deux choses différentes et je le
regrette mais après on touche à des
choses complexes qui sont qu' il ya eu
maille à devoir d'expression naturel qui
existe en france et c'est difficile
comment réguler ce ses prises de paroles
qui peuvent exister et après juste sur
l'évolution des connaissances du bébé y
compris nous alors par contre ça nous
l'assumons totalement il ya eu des
évolutions des conséquences des
connaissances sur les mécanismes de la
transmission sur le fait par exemple des
gouttelettes sur les lieux de
transmission sur l'existence de
personnes super contamina triste c'est
au fur et à mesure de la connaissance
que c'est arrivé second on a par exemple
maintenant un besoin très important de
connaître qui se contaminent comment se
contaminent et dans quelle lyon se
contaminent vous imaginez bien que pour
prendre des décisions
éventuellement si l'épidémie reprend et
bien de décision je dirais stratégique
s'appuyant sur de la science il faut
avoir cette science qui se construit or
elle se construit en même temps que les
décisions doivent être prises et c'est
là où c'est où c'est compliqué sur
l'immunité en population où vous savez
que finalement on et oscille entre 5 et
10% selon les régions de france des gens
qui ont été comme terminée par le pot
vide et qu'on des anticorps
donc ça n'est pas du tout au départ
ainsi je veux dire ça paraît totalement
naturel maintenant bon moment on
m'aurait demandé de faire un pari sur
l'immunité de population j'aurais plutôt
parié qu'on allait être à 20 à 20 ou 25
% en france on est beaucoup plus bas et
c'est dans l'ensemble des pays donc on
marche sur du sable à certains moments
sur la sur la signification des
anticorps est ce qu'on est protégé quand
on est quand on est content on a fait un
premier qu'ovide probablement oui dans
l'immense majorité des cas mais on vient
juste là dans les dernières semaines de
décrire quatre cas de contamination de
deuxième contaminations chez les gens
ayant ayant eu des anticorps tout six
tout ceci ces quelques exemples pour
vous montrer et et enfants etc au vide
entre ce qu'ils aient ce qu'ils étaient
particulièrement contaminants au
contraire comme on s'est aperçu que
finalement il était surtout contaminés
par les adultes et que c'était dans
l'autre sens ce qui se passe que ça se
passait ça a été une acquisition de
connaissances au fur et à mesure vous
voyez que les décisions les décisions
sont difficiles à prendre
voilà moi je terminerais pour d'abord
deux choses remercier l'ensemble du
conseil scientifique qui a travaillé
mais de façon vraiment extrêmement forte
en a fait plus 250 réunions sur sur
cette période
week-end je leur ai demandé énormément
de choses et j'ai les en remercie
publiquement tous et une fois de plus ce
n'est pas du tout la sphère d'un homme
c'est la sphère d'un comité et d'une
intelligence collective et c'est ça qui
m'importe
le deuxième élément c'est que je
remercie les français parce que
finalement contrairement à ce qu'on veut
bien dire et là aussi les médias ont un
rôle on s'intéressant qu'aux 20 % de
personnes qui à des degrés divers
refuges tel ou tel chose et c'est la
majorité des français 81% des français
sont sains sont un peu inquiet se
demandent comment ils vont faire comment
comment ça va se passer avec les enfants
mais pau finalement portent des masques
on va je veux dire sont dans un climat
de raisonnable et soyons dans ce climat
raisonnable et puis le troisième assez
je voudrais vous faire part d'un regret
dans notre gestion de dans un trade à la
gestion de la crise que j'ai qui reste
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans les ehpad
où nous avions repéré d'emblée et on a
et on a d'emblée donné un certain nombre
de consignes et des recommandations pour
la prise en charge des anciens dans les
ehpad
mais entre cette vision sanitaires et
cette vision une vision de laisser vivre
les anciens on s'est bien aperçu voilà
que que les ehpad était d'ailleurs
beaucoup moins médicalisé compenser un
premièrement deuxièmement que
l'organisation autour de la prise en
charge médicale dans les ehpad était
quelque chose de complexe
ce qu'on avait d'ailleurs signalé depuis
longtemps dans d'autres dans d'autres
structures et est en tout cas c'est un
des éléments qui doivent bien nous fait
réfléchir que s'il y avait une reprise
du virus dans l'est dans les semaines ou
dans les mois qui viennent on ne
recommence pas ce qui s'est passé au
sein des ehpad et que tout soit prêt
donc voilà ce que je voulais vous vous
indiquer si on a un tout petit peu de
temps mais à la fin après que vous ayez
poser les questions et que d'aimer mes
collègues et puis vous y répondre aussi
si vous souhaitez qu'on vous donne notre
vision de ce qui pourrait se passer dans
les semaines ou les mois qui viennent et
qu'on soit pas uniquement dans le passé
eh bien on pourra y aller je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président
effectivement une autre commission d
enquête n'est pas que examiner le passé
ou le présent mais également l'avenir
mais le présent est important parce
qu'on voit bien que ça bouge
alors il est de tradition après
l'intervention de nous inviter de passer
les rapports la parole à chacun des
rapporteurs et vous pourrez répondre aux
questions et ensuite de passer la parole
à nos collègues où je regroupe les
questions de nos collègues je vais
commencer par bernard jomier pour ses
premières questions merci monsieur le
président je me limiterai à deux
questions parce que je sais qu'il y en
aura beaucoup aujourd'hui la part des
collègues d'abord je voudrais remercier
très profondément les membres du conseil
scientifique parce que je sais que leur
tâche est difficile que leur engagement
est entier et je sais tu cette audition
très clairement pour nous tous le
président savary l'a rappelé et
l'occasion de chercher des réponses à
apporter pour améliorer notre attitude
collective face face à une épidémie est
donc votre contribution vos réflexions
elles sont essentielles à cet égard et
donc les deux questions auxquelles je
vais me tenir vous ces deux sujets vous
avez abordé monsieur le président la
première c'est l'existence de votre
instance qui n'est pas dont les membres
ne sont pas en cause la qualité du
travail n'est pas en cause etc
mais que signifie quand une épidémie
flambent dans un pays parce qu elle
flambait déjà quand vous avez été créé 2
créer une nouvelle instance ex nihilo et
de la faire vous l'avez rappelé ratifié
quelques temps plus tard dans son
existence par le parlement donc sa
création procédé de la seule volonté du
chef de l'état et du seul choix du chef
de l'état qu'est ce que ça dit de notre
système de santé et donc de notre site
notre préparation
à une la survenue d'une crise sanitaire
de cette ampleur est comme ça ce constat
j'ai cru comprendre que chacun avec nos
maux mais vous c'est un peu ce que vous
annonciez mais comment vous voyez la
solution à cette question puisque vous
avez rappelé vous-même que votre
instance était à durée de vie limitée je
ne sais pas si elle ira plus loin que le
30 octobre mais en tout état de cause
vous avez rappelé qu'elle n'a pas
vocation à s'inscrire dans le paysage de
la gouvernance sanitaire dans notre pays
donc le jour où elle disparaît si on
suit votre raisonnement que je partage
d'une utilité de vos travaux
eh bien il ya à nouveau quelque chose
qui ne qui ne fonctionnent plus donc
j'aimerais que vous nous vous alliez
plus loin sur cette question et ma
deuxième question elle est peut-être
encore plus complexes vous l'avez abordé
c'est la façon dont le débat
scientifique dans la controverse
scientifique est porté dans notre pays
parce que cet élément dans une période
vous l'avez rappelé où la connaissance
se construit pas à pas et on ne doit pas
juger trois mois après en oubliant que
la connaissance s'est modifié mais cette
construction devant l'opinion publique
dans une situation qui est inquiétante a
révélé des modalités qui dépassait il me
semble la légitimité du débat
scientifique et pour parler clairement
qu'ils avaient parfois plus trait à la
controverse des esgaulx qu'à autre chose
et il y à une absence de régulation
est ce lié au fait que nous sommes une
démocratie la parole est libre et c'est
heureux et tous les excès sont là mais
quand les excès prennent le pas sur
l'utilité du débat et de la controverse
scientifique c'est l'ensemble de notre
population qui en paie les conséquences
comment peut-on remédier à cet état de
fait voilà je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président si
professeur delfraissy
je réponds tout de suite écoutez je
verrai peut
premier point et puis je laisserais
daniel b la musique que si je si jade et
des membres du conseil scientifique
c'est aussi pour qu'il puisse s'exprimer
nous sommes bien d'accord et je
laisserais daniel b la musique veut
parce que c'est un des sujets kaki sur
lequel on réfléchit sur ce problème de
la régulation
sur le premier point sur pourquoi une
nouvelle instance
probablement parce qu'il manquait
quelque chose quoi y'a un long silence
qui suit votre alors je rappelle je
rappelle que nous avons été créé à la
suite de signaux d alerte que j'avais
envoyé à l'elysée
la suite de la fois de la réunion à la
baisse j'ai trouvé que les chinois nous
racontez pas grand chose j'étais l oms
ni février n'ont pas
avec ma casquette de scientifiques un
peu et enfin ayant une certaine
expérience très faible traiter beaucoup
d'humilité dans tout ça y compris pour
les comités scientifiques lui-même mais
j'étais pour le comité d'éthique pour
les enjeux éthiques qui allait se poser
pour pour la crise et c'est en revenant
bla et avec des collègues italiens qui
m'ont appelé et puis des contacts avec
simon sur les modèles de modélisation
que je me suis dit il ya quelque chose
qui ne colle plus et que donc des signes
ont été portés on a fait une réunion des
scientifiques d'une 24 scientifique à
l'elysée très multidisciplinaire aussi
le le 5 et le 5 mars et ensuite le
comité scientifique a été créé des
nouveaux danseurs dans le week-end et
puis après c'est parti
alors on aurait pu imaginer que l'état
finalement les patrons de différentes
agences par exemple santé publique
france
le haut comité de santé publique lâchait
ce que les différents responsables de
ces structures se réunissent en une
sorte de comité scientifique de patron
d' agences sanitaires pour éclairer le
gouvernement aussi dans cette vision là
c'était un premier modèle il n'a pas été
retenu
donc c'est un modèle des nouveaux de
construction des nouveaux qui a été
retenu je suis mal placé pour en parler
puisqu'on a en été les vendent à feu on
a eu les mains dans le cambouis en
france on a qu'on commence seulement à
s'interroger pour qu'on est là et on a
essayé d'abord de répondre aux questions
il me semble comme je lé indiqué que
ceux qui t'ont attente est d'être c'est
quelque chose d'un dépendants et
d'autonomie et j'ai été vous le savez
très bien patron d'une agence sanitaire
en étant directeur de la rs pendant une
période et je vois bien comment qu'on
est comme on est patron d'une agence
on est à la phase soi même mais on
défend l' agence on défend d'outils
alors que quand vous mettez un comité de
scientifiques et d'experts qui sont
indépendants et où ce sens de la
hiérarchie une fois de plus est quelque
chose de
existe et dans la plus grande politesse
bien sûr mais n'est pas directement
impliqué il ya une sorte de liberté
d'expression qui permet de se faire
alors par contre on peut se dire que
c'est dans un climat d'extrême urgence
ce type de réponse est un modèle de
réponse et quand je regarde ce qui s'est
passé au niveau européen on a les deux
modèles on a les modèles de création des
nouveaux ou honda des modèles au
contraire structuré et s'appuyant sur
des agences déjà existantes
ce qu'on pensait début juillet c'est que
je veux dire l'ensemble des agents
s'étaient mis en place et avait avait
repris la main je dirais sur un certain
nombre et que notre place donc était de
passer la main aussi à eau à l'ensemble
des agences
bon vous avez souhaité nous poursuivre
on reste avec notre indépendance
d'esprit on est capable de jeu dire de
donner des informations et de donner des
signaux d'alerté qui sont pas toujours
facile de les destiner d' alerte au plus
haut niveau de l'état
c'est pas toujours facile non plus loin
et je pense que ça c'est important mais
il faudra à un moment donné parce que ça
toujours facile se présente vous n'êtes
pas être nécessairement entendue non
c'est le le le je veux dire que c'est
passé bon bien sûr on est on est là pour
eux je dirais porter un certain nombre
de signaux d alerte
mais par exemple on air on peut être il
peut y avoir des nuances et les enjeux
par exemple maintenant sur la crise
actuelle sont loin que deux ne sont pas
seulement sanitaire ils sont aussi
également sociétaux et économiques et on
est là et on en a pleinement conscience
autour de cela donc je veux dire que
c'est dans cette dans cette relation
entre un comité scientifique et les plus
hautes autorités de l'état
bompas parler parce que j'ai indiqué
d'ailleurs mais dans un climat de
confiance une fois de plus je pense
qu'actuellement les différentes agences
sont sont que je dirais parfaitement
capables de prendre le relais et que
donc une fois de plus voilà on est
prolongée jusqu'au 30 octobre
et après on verra donc clairement
professeur notre système français
n'étaient pas prêts à la crise
voilà
daniel benamouzig souhaité la synthèse
notre président je voulais dit que le
système de santé publique et de vision
de santé public français n'étaient pas
prêts à une réponse et un tsunami de ce
type oui la réponse est oui oui
messieurs daniel benamouzig merci
monsieur peut-être quelques éléments
complémentaires par rapport à ce qu'elle
dit jean françois delfraissy c'est vrai
qu'on est dans une situation on est tous
conscience depuis le début que tout à
fait extraordinaire par par son ampleur
et par de nombreux aspects mais derrière
cette situation extraordinaire
le point sur lequel j'aimerais revenir
je vous remets pression peut-être sur
deux points le point sur lequel jean
revenir c'est qu'il ya aussi un
caractère assez ordinaire de ceux de ses
manières de fonctionner jean françois
delfraissy souligné que c'est assez
commun finalement dans le monde médical
plus largement c'est assez commun dans
le monde de l'expertisé sanitaire en
france les modes de travail qu'on a sont
des modes de travail de travail qu'on a
pour la plupart d'entre nous déjà
rencontrées parfois déjà vécu pour ce
qui me concerne à titre individuel l'an
dernier je travaillais dans le cadre
d'un conseil alors qu'ils étaient à la
fin un conseil scientifique et un
conseil de relation avec un certain
nombre de parties prenantes et qui est
un conseil indépendant sur les questions
de ddd agénésie transverse des mondes
supérieur dont les bébés sambre à la
faire des bébés sans bras vous en
souvenez dans un contexte beaucoup moins
critique évidemment que celui auquel on
a affaire aujourd'hui
mais selon des modalités d expertise qui
dans leur forme voilà sont dans un
contexte extraordinaire mais peut-être
pas dans leur de la modalité ou
peut-être pas tant que peut-être quatre
ans qu'on la dise et des modalités de
régulation qui sont assez fréquentes
dans le dans le domaine de la santé où
on a besoin d' expertise scientifique
indépendante pluraliste collégiale une
autre dimension ordinaires sur
lesquelles j'aimerais revenir c'est
peut-être aussi témoigné de de
l'intérieur si j'ose dire du travail du
conseil scientifique on regarde tous
sont ni attentif et c'est normal
le paysage un peu institutionnel la
place du conseil scientifique par
rapport à différentes instances par
rapport à différents pouvoirs par
rapport à toute une architecture
institutionnelle qu'on connaît bien et
dont on est assez friands d'ailleurs
dans notre le pays et qui caractérise
une grande démocratie en même temps dans
le fonctionnement concret le mot
d'indépendance il dit des choses très
très concrètes
il se situe dans nos modalités des
changes de délibération quotidienne jean
françois delfraissy faisait référence à
moi la plus d'une centaine sont presque
150 réunions ça veut dire qu'on se
réunit tous les jours parfois plusieurs
fois par jour jusqu'au mois de juillet
que pendant le mois d'août on continue
ce travail là et donc ont créé sur ces
bases là à travers ses délibérations ces
échanges ses doutes ses questionnements
cette manière d'aller chercher des
angles qui n'ont pas forcément été
examiné un certain moment eh bien on
finit par construire une pensée qui est
qui et collective et qui est un amalgame
finalement d'éléments à la fois connu de
certains d'entre nous parce que moi je
suis très impressionné titre personnel
par la qualité des de mes collègues qui
m'impressionne régulièrement et en même
temps il faut faire cet amalgame entre
geeks qui connaît ce qui est fondée sur
leurs connaissances scientifiques sur
leurs expériences y compris de celle des
cliniciens ou de celles d'autres types
d'acteurs et en même temps de ce qui est
pas connu de ce qui est discuté de ce
qui est débattu de ce qui est très
controversée donc la délibération et de
manière très concrète aussi l'écriture
de nos avis d'écriture de nous la
faisons nous mêmes nous la faisons si
j'ose dire avec avec le petit doigt et
nos petites et nos petits bras c'est à
dire que c'est un travail considérable
de me coucher par écrit et de stabiliser
une forme de pensée collective de de
faire en sorte qu'elle est une forme de
lisibilité à une forme de précision
quelle qu'elle embrasse bien l'ensemble
des problèmes qui sont qui sont posées
et c'est aussi par une forme d'exigence
de transparence est une manière de
rendre compte auprès de nos concitoyens
du résultat finalement de notre travail
scientifique que l'on s'attelle encore
une fois quotidiennement et parfois très
tard dans la nuit pour préparer ces
documents là pour les révise
et je vous passe sur le nombre de
versions nécessaires à l'élaboration de
chaque document ce sont des choses
concrètes que l'on vit de l'intérieur
donc c'est aussi là que se situe
l'indépendance c'est danser dans le fait
que nous avons la maîtrise de l'écrit
nous avons la maîtrise de nos
délibérations nous avons la maîtrise de
nos questionnements mère très très
concrète au lieu au delà des aspects
institutionnels sur saisine autosaisine
position hiérarchique et c'est un
deuxième point sur lequel j'aimerais
revenir puisque jean-françois mam un peu
tendu la perche c'est sûr et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est effectivement
troublant pour nous mêmes aussi cet
écart finalement entre le caractère
assez collégiale est assez consensuel à
de rares exceptions près dont on a fait
don on a fait état dans nos avis une
forme de convergence de points de vue et
d'un débat public sur les mêmes
thématiques qui lui beaucoup plus
controversée qui parfois même est
illisible qui devient rapidement
contradictoires et qui suivent des
dynamiques parfois difficile très
honnêtement très difficile à prévoir
anticiper même si au fil des mois on
voit bien la récurrence d'un certain
nombre de deux figures de schémas de
configuration comme on dit en sociologie
danser dans ces débats là ce désordre là
ils nous frappent aussi comme n'importe
quel citoyen qui cherchent à chercher à
trouver de l'information tantôt sur
internet en tout la télévision tantôt en
se référant à la confiance qu'ils
estiment pouvoir porter à tel ou tel
expert ce désordre là on doit faire avec
on doit faire avec les uns et les autres
une certaine manière il est aussi une
forme d'expression de l'autonomie et la
liberté d'un certain nombre d'acteurs la
difficulté tient au fait que sur ce type
de questions là on a une sorte de
conjonctions d'autonomie très grande et
très légitime d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs la profession médicale et
disposent et c'est très compréhensible
et c'est une construction historique qui
nous vient de loin d'une très grande
autonomie
la profession scientifique elle dispose
pour des raisons équivalente mais qui
sont un peu différentes également d'une
très grande et haute autonomie moi je
suis chercheur je suis chercheur au cnrs
je me félicite chaque jour de
l'autonomie donc je peux bénéficier dans
mon travail scientifique dans les
questionnements que je me pose dans les
recherches que je souhaite entreprendre
et c voilà c'est quelque chose qui est
partagé par tous les chercheurs
de notre pays dans une certaine mesure
évidemment beaucoup plus largement les
acteurs de la sphère médiatique dispose
aussi très légitimement d'une très
grande autonomie dans leurs manières
d'apprécier les problèmes de convoquer
les acteurs d'organiser les discussions
c'est aussi un gage de notre démocratie
et sur ce type de questionnement on a
une conjonction c'est très grande
autonomie qui ce qui se mélangent qui ce
choc et qui répondent à des logiques
assez différente mais logique du champ
médiatique se sont pas les mêmes que
celles du champ médical du champ
scientifique et ce qui me frappe pour
reprendre ce mot de régulation c'est
d'une certaine manière il ça je pense
que ça peut appeler une forme de
réflexion collective y compris des
différentes professions que l'on a fait
on a fait référence sur les modalités de
régulation on sent bien que la
régulation est difficile on sent bien
que la régulation dans le monde médical
a été compliqué que les divergences sont
difficiles à régler
alors qu'il ya des instances qui sont
prévues que ce problème là se pose
quasiment depuis toujours
donc on a une vraie difficulté à aborder
ces questions là et particulièrement
dans un contexte où on a une forte
exposition médiatique
on pourrait dire la même chose des
instances scientifiques où il ya une
forme aussi de régulation sur laquelle
on peut s'interroger quel est le rôle
des régulateurs de l'avis scientifique
sur le la manière dont un certain nombre
de positions sont présentés défendu
organisé mis en place
on faisait référence à la recherche
clinique je suis pas spécialiste de ce
domaine là mais ce sont des choses que
j'observe
on a eu un certain voilà polycentrisme
pour regarder des mots polis voir un
certain désordre dans la manière dont
tout ça a été a été mis en place donc
comment se fait cette régulation
scientifique à mon sens cela il ya
matière aussi à progresser
du point de vue de la régulation et puis
dans le domaine médiatique dans le
domaine de l'expression médiatique je
pense qu'il ya aussi
une forme de réflexion engagée par les
professionnels eux mêmes en premier chef
et peut-être aussi dans un cadre dans un
cadre civique dans un cas le citoyen sur
la régulation de ce type d'instance les
médias sont à l'affût des professionnels
qui ont légitimement à défendre une très
grande autonomie mais en même temps on
voit bien qu à des logiques qui peuvent
être des logiques mercantiles peuvent
être des logiques de durance qui peuvent
être des logiques de positionnement qui
induisent des choses qui peuvent être
ensuite assez problématique du point de
vue de leurs effets sur le débat en
santé publique et rendre responsable le
conseil scientifique de ce désordre de
ceux qui parfois est un vrai barnum
c'est voilà me semble-t-il une forme de
raccourcis qu'à titre personnel en tant
que membre du conseil scientifique je
trouve à la fois être raccourcies
audacieux et un raccourci un peu injuste
merci je vais passer dans la journée
c'est bon aussi je passe la parole à
sylvie vermine et et puis ensuite
catherine et on averti merci monsieur le
président je voudrais moi aussi
remercier professeur delfraissy et les
membres du conseil scientifique pour
nous avoir éclairé
durant la gestion de cette crise je vais
me limiter à deux questions pour que nos
collègues puissent en pause et d'autre
ces questions porteront sur l'état de
vos connaissances professeur vous y avez
fait allusion
alors la première question professeur
vous avez déclaré le 24 août
on peut imaginer des vaccins partiel au
premier trimestre 2011 21 le 10
septembre lors de nos auditions ici même
le professeur lina m'a semblé plus
réservé dans ce domaine même très
réservé pour pouvoir annoncer des délais
de sortie de deux vaccins alors qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un vaccin partiel est-ce
que vous pouvez nous nous préciser votre
votre idée sur ce point et puis une
deuxième question j'aimerais avoir votre
avis sur l'origine du coït 19
vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure que
vous étiez une réunion de l'eau et ms mi
février vous avez dit j'avais trouvé que
les chinois ne nous racontez pas grand
chose lors de cette réunion
quel est votre avis sur l'origine du
coït 19 merci de questions précises peur
premièrement sur deux sur les vaccins
bon vieux vous avez tous compris qu'on
est dans un modèle de construction
vaccinale qui est très différent de
celui qui est habituel c'est-à-dire
qu'un certain nombre de grands groupes
pharmaceutiques
s'appuyant sur des recherches issues de
start up ou deux où de grandes
universités comme oxford comme comme
d'autres grandes universités a décidé à
la fois de d'expérimenter un certain
nombre de candidats vaccins donc de
faire les phases 1 2 3 1 qui sont
l'habituel et dans le même temps de
construire et de mettre en place les
outils industriels qui permettrait une
production de vaccins à haut niveau et
c'est donc quelque chose qu'on n'avait
jamais vu puisque en général les
industriels attendent d'avoir des
premiers résultats avec leurs produits
leurs vaccins ou leurs médicaments avant
de s'engager dans un processus
industriel est là donc c'est un modèle
qui est qui
qui n'est pas d'ailleurs qui retentit
sur un ensemble de pays puisque pour
financer puisqu'ils prennent de risque
en fait ils le prennent pas totalement
puisque il demande aux différents pays
et en particulier européens ou aux états
unis et à d'autres de financer entre
guillemets en passant commande de 2
millions et 2 millions de doses qui leur
permettent d'investir dans l'outil
industriel
donc ça veut dire que on a un nouveau
modèle ou en même temps que se construit
l'élaboration d'un vaccin et son
éventuelle efficacité ou non efficacité
il ya l'outil industriel qui se
construit donc tout ça alors parmi les
différents candidats à certains on va
rester sur le carreau c'est à dire qu'on
s'apercevoir qu'ils ne ne fonctionne pas
et puis ensuite on a deux types de
vaccins pour le coc vite possible
on a des vaccins qui permettent de
diminuer je dirais la gravité des formes
des formes sévères chez les patients les
plus à risques
donc c'est c'est quelque chose de qui
épate très habituel dans la stratégie
vaccinale et puis un deuxième modèle
plus classique est celui de vaccins
préventifs évitant la transmission d'une
personne à une autre
alors ce que j'ai voulu indiquer c'est
que on aurait peut-être mais je ne le
sais pas bien sûr mais compte tenu de
cette dynamique très particulière qui
aille de l'effort considérable qui est
en train d'être menées qu'on peut
imaginer qu'on ait des parmi les blés
mettons les sept grands candidats avec
ça qu'on en ait deux ou trois qui donne
des résultats des premiers résultats
dans le premier trimestre 2010 21 et
avec des résultats partiels c'est à dire
avec un vaccin qui ne qui aurait une
efficacité en termes de transmission de
l'ordre de 50% par exemple j'ai dit ça
complètement au hasard
mais de cet ordre là donc qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec un vaccin qui permet de
transcender vite et la transmission
uniquement dans 50% des cas là c'est
déjà mieux que rien et puis peut-être
avec un vaccin qui permettrait de
réduire la fréquence et la sévérité des
formes graves qui serait qui sera
l'année des non essentiel puisque
rappelons le cette maladie dans 90 92 %
des cas
et quelque chose de relativement bénins
et que ce qui fait la gravité de cette
maladie c'est la sévérité des formera
donc voilà où on en est je pense pas que
bruno lina soit en contradiction avec
avec ce que j'ai dit on après ça c'est
difficile on n'est pas là une fois de
plus le conseil scientifique et c'est de
s'appuyer sur les données qui da on
n'est pas là pour lire dans une boule de
cristal
c'est il ya une part d'une part de
risque un peu à donner ce type de date
je pense néanmoins qu'il y aura une
évolution un tout petit peu plus rapide
que dans les stratégies vaccinales
habituel le deuxième deuxième question
sur l'origine du coc vite demi de 19
bon je sais que ça fait l'objet de
beaucoup de débats sur sur
éventuellement un virus qui serait
deux laboratoires qui se serait échappé
entre guillemets des laboratoires du p4
de one
non enfin je n'ai pas d'opinion là
dessus
1 le laboratoire p4 de one répondait
quand même des critères de sécurité de
très haut niveau ne
les technologies de chinois sont quand
même arrivés un très haut niveau
scientifique
après ce qui s'est passé exactement je
maintiens ma position qui est de dire
que les chinois nous raconte un peu ce
qu'ils veulent et que la communication
scientifique chinoise est quand même à
la fois et vos correspondants une
communication scientifique habituel avec
un certain nombre d'informations qui
sont donnés et elle est quand même sous
contrôle
sur le fond on peut imaginer qu'il
s'agit bien du schéma habituel d'un
virus qui est porté par une chauve
souris qui passe par an porteurs animal
et certains porteurs ou le savent et ont
été ont été mis en cause
il ya une rupture de la barrière
d'espèce c'est pas la première fois
c'est là il s'est produit dans une chose
pour d'autres virus important et 7 on ne
comprend pas pourquoi y ait cette
rupture de barrière d'espèce qui est
l'enjeu majeur
je rappelle que les chauves souris
vivent très bien avec ces virus et puis
ensuite ça passe chez l'homme merci mais
la stratégie vaccinale si ça ne touche
que 50% des vêtements de transmission
enfin son résultat
pensez vous qu'elle soit sociétalement
acceptable et c'est que c'est une
science en mouvement et que on peut très
bien avoir dans un premier temps un
vaccin qui est une une forme
d'efficacité qui est partielle et que ça
soit un premier candidat vaccin et qui
ensuite une amélioration de ce premier
candidat avec ça oublié par exemple la
deuxième boost avec un autre candidat et
qu'il qu'on progresse en marchant ce que
j'ai voulu indiquer c'est que on
n'aurait pas forcément dans ce délai du
1er trimestre 2011 21 le le vaccin idéal
que nous attendons tous ce qui
permettrait d'éviter la transmission à
la fois chez les anciens à la fois chez
les plus jeunes et avec une efficacité
de 99%
je ne pense pas qu'on arrive à ça je
suis même certain
on aura probablement quelque chose d'un
complet comprendra et on verra comment
ils utilisent
merci catherine des roches docteur
président je vous remercie mois-ci
l'ensemble du conseil pour son travail
pour cette audition
j'avais trois trois questions la
première
elle tient au degré de connaissance bon
le conseil a été installé le 11 mars
vous aviez sensibiliser le président la
république
cette notion fin fin janvier la ministre
de la santé se basant sans doute sur des
ce que faisait l'inserm nous disait que
le risque le virus pénètre en france
était très très faible est ce que je
voulais savoir c'est si vous dans vos
domaines respectifs vous aviez le même
degré de connaissance si oui ça voulait
dire que peut-être les modélisations de
l'inserm en fait n'était pas correct à
l'époque
et sinon si vous aviez un degré de
connaissance différent parce que
certains nous ont dit c'était le cas à
ma surprise un peu de l'association des
des patients de nous dire que eux de
leur côté avaient très en amont
puisqu'on est sur cette période un peu
un peu incertaine qui était celle qui a
suivi janvier jusqu'à début mars au où
l'épidémie est arrivé de façon très très
fort dans le grand-est eux avaient des
degré de connaissance donc calé tel
degré de connaissance et si le degré de
connaissance en france
elle n'était pas bon qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire pour améliorer dans le cadre
d'une épidémie futur la connaissance de
ce qui se passe ailleurs
on a vu qu'il y avait la chine bien sûr
mais aussi avait l'italie donc quelles
étaient les embryons de connaissance de
traitement et autres ça c'est ma
première question deuxième poids s'est
alors lâché par complètement sur la
situation actuelle
on a vu pendant la gestion par par les
soignants de cette épidémie notamment
par exemple la région ile de france a
appris ce qui se faisait dans le grand
est
ils ont appris des choses il ya eu une
période d'apprentissage qui a fait on
l'a vu dans l'évolution des des
traitements de l'animation dans la mise
en place d anti coagulantes certains
anti inflammatoires assez stable
moi ma question c'est maintenant si
l'épidémie repart on voit qu'on est sur
une situation territorialisée plus plus
lâche si je puis dire avec des des
patients et des clusters en aveyron il
ya des connaisseurs dans des
départements où il n'ya pas des grands
centres hospitaliers
est ce que quelqu'un est chargé de
donner des modèles des guides et des
consignes parce que la chasse aux biens
des absents alors je sais que souvent
les cons les conseils ou les fiches
pratiques ou les bonnes pratiques ne
sont données que sur sur des assurances
qui n'existent pas forcément
actuellement on est dans un flou donc il
ya une prudence mais en matière
d'épidémie nouvelle et crise comme ça la
prudence elle a ses limites et elle
entraîne forcément des pertes de chance
donc est ce qu'il y a actuellement cours
des des conseils pour qu'il y ait des
échanges de réseau un vrai maria un vrai
maillage territorial entre certains
hôpitaux et des centres de référence et
par exemple pour les généralistes au
départ ils ont été complètement exclu en
défaut aller au samu sur les
généralistes par exemple on sait qu'il
ya des biomarqueurs et autres qui est
chargé de donner ses consignes et est à
mon sens c'est assez urgent donc je
voudrais savoir si vous partagez cet
avis et le troisième point qu'elle
correspond une question que vous a posé
et qui concerne les essais cliniques
c'était comment on peut concilier dans
ces temps de crise sanitaire d'une
épidémie nouvelles avec des tâtonnements
thérapeutique il nécessité d'apporter
une réponse thérapeutique rapide aux
malades parce que les one and only on se
retrouvait face à des des patients et on
essayait toutes les thérapeutiques
existantes pour pouvoir les tirer
d'affaires et la conduite de travaux
scientifiques
corot bus pour en effet s'assurer de
l'efficacité d'un traitement ce qui est
le but des essais est ce que est ce que
le ça a été facile à concilier parce
qu'on a des essais cliniques des braques
était purement d'antiviraux n'y a pas eu
vraiment de bras anti inflammatoires est
ce que ça ne génère pas ça n'a pas pu a
généré une perte de chance pour ce qui
du fait de critères n'étaient pas
rentrées dans les essais cliniques en a
mais trois questions président écoute et
je vais répondre partiellement alors sur
sur l'état des connaissances en moi je
rappelle que le conseil scientifique et
a débuté donc le 10 mars donc on a
trouvé une situation
le 10 mars je dis moi avec eux très
grande simplicité
vraiment alors d'abord que j'avais
c'était pas dans mon agenda au cg j'ai
eu 72 ans au mois de mai c'était pas
dans mon agenda de repartir sur un truc
aussi actif
j'ai eu entre les mains quand même
beaucoup de choses sur le vih
ensuite on m'a confié ebola et je
n'avais pas mis dans mon agenda c'est
donc
je j'ai été avec une vision une fois de
plus de 2 des grandes conséquences
éthiques que posait ses épidémies et
puis je n'ai commencé vraiment moi donc
à me réveiller entre guillemets j'ai
laissé passer mois de janvier très très
tranquillement gardons comme tout le
monde comme vous comme bon et c'est
vraiment cette réunion à le ms où
j'étais pour autre chose ou g où j'ai
trouvé que les chinois n'étaient pas
claires on les a eu deux fois en vidéo
conférence en deux heures on pouvait
leur poser des questions
il ne répondait pas sur des choses aussi
simples et voyez des formes graves c'est
qui c'est des sujets âgés ils sont
ventilés combien de temps x je suis un
clinicien mode fondamentalement donc
c'est une question que je peux poser et
gg j'ai gueulé auprès l'époque de de
l'om est 110 ans et c'est de la langue
de bois pour une partie de ce qui est en
train d'être discutés bon ensuite des
collègues italiens de la mi-février
m'ont interpellé et les italiens du nord
sont très brillants ces îles foyer on
les a considérés en disant c'est vitaly
s'est passé est entièrement faux ils
sont beaucoup plus liées aux équipes
américaines que nous sommes en france
voyez il ya ces connexions qui sont
extrêmement pas et qui m'ont appelé dans
ce milieu et mythologies en disant si un
orage inflammatoires des cytokines que
vous évoquez qu'est ce qui est en train
de caisse qui est en train de se passer
et puis enfin c'est des discussions avec
les modélisateurs donc tout ça pour vous
dire que moi finalement un peu quand
même pas vraiment et en plus tout à fait
dans le bain complètement et en
particulier auprès des politiques
mais quand même étant dans le bain dans
ma dans ma formation de scientifiques
autour des autour des crises sanitaires
je ne me suis vraiment réveillé que
mi-février donc je suis très humble je
suis très humblement
alors après je laisse sur ces sur les
modèles et sur est-ce qu'on avait des
signaux d alerte sur les modèles et sur
la partie épidémiologique
sinon tu peux peut-être un dit quelque
chose qui je répondrais l'autre question
donc là on se projette en janvier donc
donc c'est il ya beaucoup de signaux
d'alerté en fait qu'ils sont venus
justement du monde de la modélisation
c'est à dire que l'un des premiers
signaux très inquiétant c'était une
analyse faite mi janvier je pense où les
chinois rapportait une quarantaine de
cas confirmés est en fait permis donc il
y avait 44 confirme 40 à peu près cas
confirmé en chine et par ailleurs si
déjà six cas à l'international est en
fait si vous faites juste le regard d'un
petit peu les flux de passagers entre la
chine et l'international s'il ya sika à
l'international sait déjà que c'est très
très développé en chine et donc en
regardant le finalement le sait qu'à
l'international on pouvait déjà dire
qu'il y avait sans doute quelques
milliers de d'infection sur le
territoire chinois et suite à sa très
rapidement après ce que ce que cette
étude soit soit sorti en fait les
chinois ont revu complètement à la
hausse les
on commence a déclaré bien plus de cas
donc ça c'était un signal très
inquiétant pour l'ensemble de la
communauté scientifique
après ce qu'il faut voir c'est que nous
qui travaillons sur les émergence d
émergence y en a en fait assez souvent
et en 2009 vous souvenez sans doute les
premières estimations de la mortalité de
la grippe pandémique de 2009 elles
étaient à peu près entre 0 5 et 1% donc
ce qu'on a maintenant ce qu'on estime
maintenant pour le pour le comique 19
pasco tout démarrage on sait qu'on va
sur et on va avoir tendance à surestimer
la mortalité
parce que l'on voit que les cas sévères
qui vont à l'hôpital et que donc voilà
on a ce problème et donc il ya donc
l'ensemble de la communauté scientifique
a été très inquiète au démarrage de 2009
et puis progressivement on a vu que
finalement la de la sévérité s'était pas
0,5 ou 1 % c'était c'était plutôt du
deux pour dix mille donc complètement un
ordre de grandeur complètement différent
ce qui fait que je pense qu'il ya eu
tout un moment où on était un petit peu
en attente de savoir si les signaux sur
la sévérité allait se confirmer ou pas
et ça donc ça a pris un peu de temps
donc si moi je regarde un petit peu
comment ma position a évolué pendant
pendant cette période là ce que
j'expliquais c'était qu'on pouvait en
effet d'être dans un scénario de
sévérité très importante avec le 0 5 1 %
de mortalité mais c'était pas impossible
que progressivement on s'aperçoive que
la sévérité baisse quand en fait on
commence à mieux qu'on a mieux détecter
les infections donc il ya il ya ceux là
on parle beaucoup de doutes et il ya une
période quand même de doute où on était
vraiment dans la tente aussi à se
demander si les chinois qui mettait un
moment quand même ont mis en place des
mesures sans précédent de confinement
allait réussir à stopper la propagation
à la source ou au contraire que ça se
propage à l'international donc il ya eu
toute une période de doute ou là la
communauté scientifique était un petit
peu dans en effet en attente de voir
vraiment ce qu'est l'espace et estimer à
combien la sévérité pour le coc vide
vous avez parlé de deux pour dix mille
pour la grippe pour 2011 est donc
maintenant ouais donc en fait
si vous lisez notre avis du 12 mars
on est on estimait qu'il y avait une une
mortalité lorsqu'on est infecté entre 0
5 et 1% qui était à l'époque basé sur
pas beaucoup de données donc depuis on a
fait bien plus d' analyse en gardant les
les patterns de mortalité dans 45 pays
ou dans quinze de ces pays on a de la
sérologie donc maintenant on a beaucoup
plus de données et en fait on reste dans
ce même ordre de grandeur entre 0 5 et
1%
sachant quand même que on est face à un
virus ou le le concept même de mortel de
donner un chiffre pour la mortalité n'a
pas beaucoup de sens parce que toute la
mortalité se retrouve dans quelques
groupes et que donc bien entendu s'il ya
un petit peu plus ou un petit peu moins
d'infections dans ces groupes on peut
vraiment avoir un très gros impact sur
la moyenne donc c'est c'est
contrairement à d'autres virus faut pas
juste penser en termes de moyenne mais
vraiment en termes de distribution de
mortalité passé 1 % des décès durant la
première phase de mars et son chez les
sujets de plus de 65 ans ayant une
pathologie x ou y sûr a ajouté don
concerne bien alors ça me permet de
répondre à votre deuxième question qui
est est ce qu'on est
est-ce qu'on a tiré des leçons pour la
prise en charge des patients je vais
donner tous les éléments c'est à dire
que les réanimateurs ont appris à mieux
les prendre en charge c'est un classique
dont les formes graves
c'est dire que les équipes médicales
apprennent et donc optimise le type de
résultats et en particulier décidé de
retarder la ventilation sur par un tube
à sion on a maintenant des résultats
solides décès alors la solide sur les
anti-inflammatoires soit les corticoïdes
soit dans une certaine aussi mesure
l'est des antilles récepteur 2006 le
problème d'un effet de la co-régulation
et donc votre
votre question me fait pas sourire mais
j'ai on a dans notre avis numéro numéro
8 du mois de juillet on a indiqué que
les recherches devaient déjà posé les
questions dès début août pour anticiper
ce qui se passerait avec les formes
graves à la mi-septembre et je pense que
liliane henriette en plein à vous
répondre à g vient je viens de vérifier
il ya quatre jours que des consignes qui
donne les consignes 1 c et bien c'est
alors c'est ce et des sociétés savantes
alors vous avez 2 2 types de conseil
vous avez soit passant par la chaise
inquiétude qui est un premier une
première forme soi qui peut passer aussi
par le haut comité de santé publique
un sur certains aspects et puis quand
c'est très médical très technique c'est
souvent je dirais par exemple la société
c ils se sont regroupés entre la société
des réanimations la société des
infectiologues et la société des
anesthésistes réanimateurs et des
gériatres puisque ça touche les patients
les plus âgés et là ils font des
recommandations de sociétés savantes qui
viennent de sortir pour la prise en
charge uniforme est relativement
homogène des formes sévères dans
l'épidémie actuelle je vous ai répondu
exactement où on en est alors pour les
médecins généralistes yaya zan plana
vous en parlera cet après midi il ya eu
un flottement
je vous l'avais souligné et sur
l'organisation des essais thérapeutiques
il vous le dira dans le cadre de
reacting il ya un gros médecins
généralistes maintenant avec un médecin
généraliste qui fait partie du conseil
scientifique de reacting et il ya pour
les essais thérapeutiques qui sont
menées et coordonnée à partir du mois de
septembre puisque c'est dans le rôle de
reacting mais ça les seuls on est bien
là dans la régulation qui est évoqué
tout à l'heure ça bien de seulement
d'être décidée par les deux ministères
et bien les médecins généralistes seront
dort mieux qu'ils ne l'ont été au mois
d'avril ou ou s'est fait beaucoup de
petits essais etc
sur le troisième point les essais
cliniques comment peut-on mener des
essais cliniques de qualité dans une
situation de crise sanitaire
j'ai pas totalement la réponse
j'ai même banc fin j'avais même écrit
que dans certaines circonstances on
pouvait être amené à prendre un certain
nombre de décisions qui ne relèvent pas
de l'essai clinique en devises et je les
écris pour ebola mais rappelons que la
mortalité des mollahs elles étaient de
l'ordre de 75% au début 1 donc il ya
quand même une différence entre 75 % de
mortalité est ce les chiffres que vient
de vous indiquer simon cauchoise et même
dans ebola eh bien on a on a manqué
finalement d'un grand essai randomisé
qui nous permettent de trancher
définitivement sur le type de
médicaments qui était qui était faisable
donc il me semble que y compris en
situation de crise sanitaire
il faut respecter au maximum autant que
faire se peut les bonnes pratiques
cliniques qui existent en situation de
non crise sanitaire
on les modulant et en faisant que le
maximum de patients puissent être inclus
dans les essais de façon à apporter une
réponse le plus rapidement possible
alors est-ce que ça a été totalement
réalisée
la réponse est non parce que c'est
difficile les anglais l'ont mieux
réalisais que nous puisque le système
anglais a imposé dans son système nhs
que les essais thérapeutiques plus soit
je veux dire fasse partie intégrante de
la prise en charge reacting l'a en
partie fait mais en partie seulement
elias en lisant pas là vous expliquera
pourquoi mais je veux dire que la crise
sanitaire doit la réponse n'est pas
seulement au niveau de l'individu mais
elle est au niveau du groupe d'individus
et on peut être amené à privilégier
finalement d'attendre un tout petit peu
mais d'avoir une réponse solide donc
concernant un groupe d'individus pour
mieux aller ensuite traiter un individu
donné mais c'est d'une vraie question
éthique qui était de l'éthique de la
recherche et qui est une vraie question
merci bien nous allons passer aux
questions de nos collègues douze sons
sont inscrits donc nous prenons les
questions quatre par quatre pour que
essayez donc merci d'être précis dans la
question
roger karoutchi le président mesdames et
messieurs du conseil au jour et une
observation simple la france
globalement y compris les morts à
domicile 40 mille morts ça peut faire
réfléchir et réfléchir différemment
simplement d'un constat philosophique
en réalité ce que nous ne sommes pas
trompés dès le départ qui a mieux réussi
clos soit les états autoritaires qui ont
par l'autorité sans forcément avoir une
structure scientifique à côté d'eux pris
des mesures d'une telle vigueur
qu'effectivement on a limité la
propagation soit des états qui avait une
structure scientifique mais qui ne
voulant pas avoir de responsabilités
politiques se sont souvent contentés de
dire nous faisons strictement ce que le
conseil peut importe l'appellation
locale scientifique décide et nous nous
avons choisi
curieusement la solution de ni l'un ni
l'autre
pas assez d'autorité pour prendre des
mesures fermes
un conseil scientifique et médéa vie
mais on s'empresse de dire que le
politique conserve la décision et n'est
pas tenu de suivre les avis et le
résultat c'est que nous avons souvent
louvoyé souvent donné le sentiment à
l'opinion publique on ne savait pas
clairement
dallest et ça ça continue le tout
renforcé effectivement par des débats
télévisés assez chaotique où chacun
venait dire sa part de vérité ou peu
importe
en tout cas le tout n'éclairant
personnes est ce que vous n'avez pas le
sentiment qu'il eût mieux valu quand on
entend parfois des responsables
gouvernementaux aujourd'hui dire quand
ça les arrange
après avis du conseil scientifique et on
suit la vie
et quand ça les arrange pas on ne fait
pas référence aux conseils scientifiques
et on prendre d'autres mesures
est-ce qu'il n'eut pas mieux valu avoir
une règle simple le débat télé le débat
médiatique est ce qu'il est mais en
revanche les avis du conseil
scientifique
objectif travailler j'allais dire neutre
par rapport à tout ce que peuvent être
les intérêts dans les débats médiatiques
c'est à vila doivent être suivies je
veux prendre un seul exemple très récent
monsieur le président et moi j'étais
tout à fait d'accord à la vue des
remontées des contaminations récente
vous avez dit la semaine dernière le
gouvernement va devoir annoncer des
mesures fermes des mesures fortes pour
en réalité faire en sorte que cette
pandémie ne repartent pas et puis nous
avons eu la conférence de presse du
premier ministre ou en fait il ya eu
aucune annonce
aucune annonce alors est ce que là
dessus on a pas entre le politique et le
conseil scientifique
un vrai problème si la pandémie reprend
ce qui semble être le cas
est ce que pour rendre confiance aux
français il faut pas donner le sentiment
que le politique et scientifique
travaille ensemble et de père et non pas
en étant tellement indépendants l'un de
l'autre
on se demande réellement où on voit elle
si olivier henno oui merci monsieur le
président ma question est assez voisines
et elle part du constat qui a été fait
que le système français n'était pas prêt
et donc
ma question est la suivante selon vous
est-ce que ça a toujours été le cas
ou est-ce que c'est sous la pression
économique ou d'autres pressions que
nous avons baissé la garde
et puis en complément un peu de la
question de roger karoutchi
quel pays au singulier ou pluriel était
le mieux préparé
quel pays est aujourd'hui le mieux
préparé je vous remercie
jasmin oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président d'être ici j'ai
pour vous trois questions alors une qui
concerne les relations que vous avez pu
avoir avec les instances de démocratie
sanitaire
ce qu'il y en a eu la deuxième concerne
la boue venez de dire l'innovation
thérapeutique et très peu arrivent et
donc dans le domaine du diagnostic par
comté du dépistage il ya eu de
l'innovation avez vous déjà évaluer les
différents tests
on a plusieurs possibilités on les sait
mais quels sont les plus pertinents
aujourd'hui est un levier vos
connaissances des moyens humains et
matériels dont disposaient les deux
laboratoires de biologie
quand vous avez conseillé au
gouvernement de faire les différentes
dépistage qui ont été faits sous les
formats les différents formats curité
réalisées à ce jour concernant également
leur côté stratégique et géopolitique
avez vous pris en compte la situation de
la france qui est un archipel l'archipel
france avec ses territoires d'outre-mer
et particulièrement la guyane qui est
une paire française en amérique du sud
alors avez vous un moment donné pris en
compte ces difficultés compte tenu de la
situation par rapport aux différentes
frontières parce qu'on se fondera sur
l'hexagone les zones frontalières ont
été gérés d'une certaine manière alors
que dans les autres mers sap a été géré
de la même manière et concernant les
anticorps vous en avait parlé il ya eu
au début des interventions on a fait
constater qu'il ya des personnes qui ont
eu une deuxième contamination alors
concernant la production dont des
anticorps et la réponse immunitaire par
rapport au vaccin est ce que vous
préconisez est ce que vous allez suggéré
qu'il y ait de la recherche
sur les personnes qui ont déjà eu lieu
au vide pour voir quelle est la réponse
immunitaire et est ce qu'il y a qui est
opportun de vacciner ou faire vacciner
ces personnes parce que là il ya une
grande interrogation d'après ce qui
vient d'être dit ce que vous avez
complété par rapport à ce qu'elle était
du temps de staline
je vous remercie merci annie guillemot
oui merci monsieur président moi j'aurai
deux questions la première question est
un petit peu une interpellation parce
que on entend toujours effectivement
dire que le temps du politique est
différent des médias est différent des
scientifiques je veux bien mais vous
avez dit professeur delfraissy que la
science se construit sur les
incertitudes je ne suis pas sûr
aujourd'hui que depuis très longtemps
que la politique se construit pas non
plus sur des incertitudes vu la
situation internationale et il me semble
quand même que le rôle du politique
c'est justement de gérer ces
incertitudes et donc moi j'ai vraiment
j'interpelle ça parce que ça fait
tellement longtemps alors en boucle en
ce moment et ça me suis un peu rebelle
ça me met en colère
justement sur ces incertitudes il ya eu
la vie on a vu le docteur crozier qui
nous a parlé d'éthique et il ya eu la
vie je crois 106 du conseil du ccn
éthique et est ce que par rapport à ces
incertitudes qui soit sur la situation
politique internationale on le voit
aujourd'hui avec tout ce qui se passe
turquie grèce et migrants mais aussi sur
l'évolution de notre société notamment
sur la prise en compte de la précarité
par rapport à des pandémies et ce qu'il
ne faut pas justement mettre en oeuvre
des conseils scientifiques mais aussi
qui font appel aux sciences humaines et
sociales et pas seulement économiques
pour qu on refonde un certain nombre je
dirais de commandes d'assentiment en
tout cas quelque chose qui nous
rassemble sur un certain nombre de
points
et j'aimerais bien avoir votre votre
position parce que dans la vie du
conseil d'éthique
on dit que le conte le questionnement
éthique amène souvent à confronter le
principe d'autonomie et l'exigence de
solidarité mais surtout les dossiers on
né au coeur la du sujet et surtout sur
les pandémies et je trouve que le
docteur crozier nous nous a bien
éclairer là dessus ma deuxième question
elle revient là plus terre à terre entre
sur l'organisation vous avez dit il
manquait sans doute quelque chose on a
fait le conseiller scientifique
alors si on a d'autres pandémies est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas qu'on
réfléchisse à qu'est-ce qu'on change on
à la rn1 nous on voit les parlementaires
on a le préfet on à la rs en la santé
publique france il ya même des gens qui
connaissent pas du tout santé publique
france je me rappelle de ce que disait
madame busin lors de son audition à
l'assemblée nationale sur le problème
entre santé publique france les ars clé
masque elle disait que la gestion du
stock stratégique des masses de
protection ne revenait pas au ministre
mais était de la responsabilité de la
chance santé publique france qu'il
fallait questionner le rôle des agences
sanitaires qu'il y avait des
interrogations sur l'ensemble et que les
compétences de gestion de crise la
réactivité avait été diluée et c'est
qu'il faut elle préconise une agence
dédiée aux crises en général et pas
seulement sanitaire
quel est votre avis aussi là dessus et
par rapport à et j'ai fini là dessus par
rapport aux hôpitaux est ce qu'il faut
continuer à fermer des lits d'hôpitaux
merci je vous demanderais d'être aussi
con si dans les réponses merci
professeur seulement que ceux des
collègues vont pouvoir répondre aussi ce
nom sur la première question est ce que
le modèle français de relations et
activités scientifiques vis-à-vis du
politique
un peu intermédiaire comme et est-il le
bon par rapport à d'autres modèles
écoutez moi je pense qu'il est encore
trop tôt pour retirer les leçons
il va y avoir plusieurs points il va y
avoir le le nombre de décès pour 100000
habitants qui sera un chiffre bon ou la
france va se situer probablement en
cinquième ou sixième position parmi les
grandes puissances mondiales
je rappelle que c'est la plus grande
puissance mondiale les états unis qui va
se trouver en tête
le deuxième élément c'est le
retentissement économique et sociétal
parce que autant la question sanitaire
était dominante au mois de mars
autant soyez en persuader sur l'ensemble
des membres du comité scientifique
on est on est persuadé la maintenant que
les enjeux sont la fois sanitaire mais
aussi sociétaux et économiques et même
que dans le sanitaire
il ya deux sanitaires kelly locaux vides
et avec une reprise possible de
l'épidémie il ya le sanitaire qui est
liée aux colis de moins et les services
de réanimation qui eux qui ont été
utilisées au mois de mars et qui était
une fois de plus à 90% ou 95% dédié aux
comics c'est impossible maintenant
marseille bordeaux on fera des choix de
peut-être 30 % liée au comique parce que
sinon on aurait sûrement visite est liée
au non coté
alors je dévie un peu mais c'est pour
vous montrer qu'on est totalement
persuadé on est des citoyens comme comme
vous ouvre et on est totalement persuadé
que le sanitaire ne doit pas être
uniquement dominante dominante dominant
et qui doit s'inscrire dans quelque
chose et 2 le deuxième élément dans la
relation avec le politique
écoutez moi je les dis en toute
franchise je les des relations étaient
se sont construites avec une certaine
forme de sérénité et globalement quand
même l'immense majorité des
préconisations du conseil scientifique
ont été suivies j'ai sauf sur trois
points je vais rappeler où on était on
avait une vision un peu différente de
l'école et de la et de l'ouverture des
écoles au mois deux hautbois de début
mai deuxièmement sûr on y reviendra sur
la place du comité citoyen et de la
société civile dans le don le don je
dirais ce qui peut amener à aider à
éclairer une décision là on n'a pas du
tout été suivi
et troisièmement dans l'évaluation
actuelle la de la reprise ou pas de
l'épidémie
mais on est quand même dans la nuance
les la réaction du premier ministre a
été et nous l'avions indiqué qu'il
fallait se s'intéresser aux grandes
métropoles et construire une réaction
des métropoles avec les ars les préfets
et les progrès et les politiques au
niveau des grandes métropoles
c'est ce qui finalement est en train de
se passer à marseille et à bordeaux peut
être à rennes et on verra donc on est on
est globalement je dirais que il n'y a
pas eu de dissociation tels que tel que
vous le l'envisager mais c'est toujours
difficile âge de moi en tant que citoyen
d'un comité scientifique qui a une
certaine responsabilité et comment on
fait passer un certain nombre de
messages
on sait comment les faire passer mais
comment le politique qui a une vision
plus globale les prend en compte
alors après ce qu il ya des pays
européens qui ont mieux marché que nous
oui
ah bon c'est we say à l'allemagne et à
l'allemagne qui est qui et probablement
pour des raisons à la fois culturel de
d'organisation des länder du nombre de
lits de réanimation par part pour dix
mille habitants en allemagne qui est
très largement supérieur cloud ou sur
tout l'ensemble de l'allemagne honda des
ratios qui sont comparables à ceux qui
en région parisienne c'est qu'ils sont
ceux de la région parisienne très
largement supérieurs à ceux qui en
province c'est un c'est un des éléments
de la réponse
et puis il ya eu neuf oublions pas que
même que dans les deux grands enjeux de
lutte contre l'épidémie
c'est la distanciation physique et la
capacité à tester tracé isolé tester
tracé isolé et sur la distanciation
physique
les allemands ont été plus sages que
nous c'est très clair mais il ya une
culture ancienne qui est autour de ça
des pays du nord et deuxièmement ils ont
testé beaucoup plus rapidement que nous
durant la phase 2 fin janvier et du mois
de février qui sont décrits sont des
mois qui est le moins peu critique comme
cela a été souligné et donc ils ont pu à
ce moment là à voir une pandémie qui est
des plus faibles et troisièmement il ya
eu un élément chance ou malchance pour
la france c'est l'épisode de mulhouse
on n'aurait pas eu probablement bleus
arnaud fontanet déjà dû vous le dire on
n'aurait pas eu mulhouse on se serait
trouvé dans une situation probablement
intermédiaire un peu moins bien que
l'allemagne est un peu mieux que là où
on est arrivé début mars sur les sur les
systèmes sur la démocratie sanitaire
peut-être il faut qu'on y insiste un
petit peu peut-être mari elle était et
daniel voulait reprendre un peu ça et je
répondrai sur les aspects d'outre-mer
après mais pour vous dire qu'on a été
très sensible à ce ce message de
démocratie sanitaire à la main mais dis
moi monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs je ne suis ni scientifique ni
médecin je suis présidente d'akd et des
quart monde et j'ai été nommé dans le
conseil scientifique par le président
larcher pour que les plus pauvres ne
soient pas les oubliés de cette crise
sanitaire et je dois dire que dès le
premier jour où j'ai rejoint le conseil
dans nos réunions journalières
par téléphone j'ai été frappé par
l'attention de mes collègues à cette
problématique de ne pas oublier les plus
pauvres dans cette crise sanitaire et
vous pourrez le remarquer dans chacun
des avis du conseil
chacun des avis du conseil nous avons à
chaque fois fait des préconisations sur
tel ou tel point le logement le
sanitaire les les bureaux de poste qui
doivent être davantage ouverts etc pour
porter l'intention du politique sur les
plus pauvres dans cette crise sanitaire
alors si si l'attention a été portée sur
un certain nombre de points comme un
certain nombre de milliers de personnes
qui ont été relogées provisoirement
puisqu'elle était à la rue jeu pour ne
pas prendre la parole pendant trop
longtemps mais quand même
pour vous dire qu'au début de cette
crise sanitaire il y avait dans notre
pays
9 millions 3 de personnes qui vivaient
sous le seuil de pauvreté qu'à ce jour
nous n'avons pas encore les chiffres
mais avec mes amis des associations qui
mènent le même combat que le nôtre nous
envisageons plutôt un chiffre au delà
des 10 millions de personnes qui vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté
ce que je veux souligner c'est qu'à ce
jour malheureusement les plus pauvres
sont vraiment les grands oubliés du plan
de relance et que les quelques miettes
qui ont été distribués aux plus pauvres
avec les 100 euros d'allocation de
rentrée scolaire ne suivent pas du tout
tout ce qui a été suivi par le politique
pendant le confinement et c'est pour moi
une grande déception que je me permets
de vous partager ici
merci de l'avoir rappelé monsieur plus
sensibles permettez ça ne répond pas à
la question que j'ai posée
il existe justement les conférences de
santé de l'autonomie partout sur le
territoire et il existe également des
commissions spécialisées des droits des
usagers
voilà donc été hors des missions qui
sont précises donc je voudrais avoir une
réponse qui soit qui se rapproche
beaucoup plus de la démocratie sanitaire
dans le cadre de la csd la réponse doit
être complété un puisqu'il ya monsieur
benhamou ci qui complète
on n'a pas oublié oui effectivement ça
c'est un point extrêmement important
cette question de la démocratie
sanitaire et plus généralement du bien
entre les espaces professionnels disons
de de la santé le reste elle reste des
citoyens dans la situation de d'urgence
qu'on a qu'on a connus qu'on a connus au
printemps force est de constater que ce
lien là ne s'est pas fait dans les
relations les modalités habituelles
selon les modalités prévues et donc il
ya eu à avoir une réflexion pour essayer
autant que possible de pallier cette
difficulté là je pense que c'est cette
difficulté elle interroge de nous
interroger tous y compris sur sur le
caractère
voilà sur la sur la capacité aussi de
ses institutions à s'emparer d'un
certain nombre de sujets elles sont
supposées aussi avoir une capacité
d'interpellation de participation active
au débat public et d'une certaine
manière ce sont ces éléments là qui doit
être favorisée je pense que ça peut
appeler aussi une réflexion une
réflexion à froid sur leur place sur
leur rôle dans le système de santé
auprès des différentes institutions
existantes pour ce qui nous concerne
encore une fois à l'échelle qui est la
nôtre qui est une quête une échelle qui
certes a eu un rôle éminent dans cette
dans cette crise mais qui ne saurait
résumer l'ensemble des institutions
sanitaires on a constamment appelé vous
le retrouverez dans nos avis vous le
retrouverez dans des prises de position
parfois qu'on a fait publiquement avec
un certain nombre d'acteurs du monde
associatif du monde sanitaire du monde
scientifique en appelant constamment au
renforcement de ce dialogue là je pense
qu'il n'est pas trop tard
je pense qu'on rentre dans une logique
on le voit bien qu il logique plus
territoriale qui est logique à vocation
aussi impliqué des élus territoriaux
dans l'ensemble des décisions qui sont
prises
il serait assez normal que dans ce cadre
là une parole citoyenne soit constituée
en tout cas je crois que nous y serions
très favorable nous sommes déjà à
plusieurs reprises prononcé par écrit
dans ce sens la dent dans nos avis dont
il ya certainement des éléments qui sont
améliorable convocation elle il ya des
choses qui ont été faites à titre
personnel je représente le conseil
scientifique dans un comité de contrôle
et de liaison qui a été qui a été créé
pour contrôler en particulier aspect les
aspects numérique qui est présidée par
par un éminent collègue et président de
la conférence nationale de santé c'est
évidemment pas tout à fait un hasard si
on a sept
cette conjonction là c'est aussi une
manière de de favoriser des discussions
avec avec avec ses différents mons et
ses différents mondes
je pense que c'est un premier pas c'est
un mandat qui à mon sens c'est un peu
restrictif sur une question qui est
certainement importante qui mériterait
une réflexion dans le sens d'un
élargissement
pour ce qui est des aspects citoyens
j'espère que ça apportera quelques
quelques éléments de réponse à la
question qui a été posée sur cette
thématique là j'ai même si vous
permettez monsieur le président de
garder la parole brièvement sur sur
quelques autres points il a été
mentionné très justement que différentes
dimensions sociales au sens très large
du terme qui excède la dimension
sanitaire gagnerait à être prises en
compte
voilà nous sommes deux spécialistes en
sciences sociales qui ne sommes pas
économiste donc pour l'un par
sociologues et on travaille en étroite
liaison avec une collègue une collègue
anthropologue qui a abordé aussi un
certain nombre de questions importantes
qui quel est notre rôle pendant quelques
mots dans deux ans devant essence en
relançant voilà sans trop m'étendre
j'insisterai sur deux points le premier
point c'est que presque par formation on
regarde tous les phénomènes sociaux
comme des phénomènes qui sont stratifié
socialement on n'est pas égaux vis-à-vis
de l'information on n'est pas égaux
vis-à-vis du service des services de
santé on n'est pas égaux par rapport aux
risques con con qu'on subit on n'est pas
voilà donc donc on regarde
systématiquement cette dimension là et
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on peut être
attentif à certaines catégories
particulièrement vulnérables de notre
population pour des raisons médicales
pour des raisons
pour des raisons sociales c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
qu'on est aussi très attentifs on essaie
de l'être en tout cas et on alerte et
très tôt sur ces aspects là sur des
dimensions qui dépassent des aspects
médicaux qui ne rentrent pas d'ailleurs
forcément dans des aspects économiques
mais qui vont renvoyer à des dimensions
à des risques psychiques qui vont
renvoyer à des à ce qui se passe
malheureusement une fois que la médecine
a échoué et que et que des décès
interviennent voilà sont des éléments
sur lesquels à plusieurs reprises vous
le retrouverez dans différents avis on a
consulté alerté pris contact parfois
avec avec certains acteurs pour éclairer
pour éclairer nos points de vue et le
dernier point je m'arrêterai vraiment
monsieur le président sur ce point là il
a été posé la question de savoir si
certaine manière cette difficulté de
préparation certes certain degré
d'impréparation qu'on a tous ceux vécus
venaient de loin oui je crois qu'il
vient de loin il vient même de très loin
on a un pays dans lequel le système de
santé pour des raisons historiques
compréhensible débattues discutées à
différents moments de notre histoire a
été un système très curatif il présente
delfraissy
lorsqu'il s'est exprimé devant
l'assemblée nationale a insisté à mon
sens après juste raison sur le déficit
de capacité de moyens en matière de
santé publique
il ya des choses qu'on voit sert quand
on voit que certains acteurs de santé
publique qu'en vue d'ailleurs leurs
moyens réduits au fil des années par
différentes lois de financement de la
sécurité sociale de manière de manière
relativement régulière mais surtout on
ne voit pas un certain nombre d'acteurs
qui n'ont jamais émergé jamais été créé
on a une santé communautaire au niveau
local qui est balbutiante
quand on s'est posé la question des
modalités par lesquelles on pouvait
imaginer des dépistages des modalités de
traçage
on n'a pas des acteurs qui sont nombreux
qui sont opérationnels et on avait
appelé aussi une action dans ce sens là
dans nos différents avis de manière plus
générale la santé publique n'est pas à
de mon point de vue personnel n'est pas
à la hauteur des vulnérabilités
auxquelles nos sociétés sont désormais
exposés
l'épisode que nous traversons
aujourd'hui est un épisode dramatique
mais nous pourrions connaître d'autres
au moins aussi dramatique
je suis pas sûr que l'on soit équipé et
je suis pas sûr que quel que soit son
excellence et quel que soit le
dévouement des professionnels qui
exercent le système de soins suffira à
faire face à ces aspects a donc vraiment
cette question de la santé publique en
tant que domaine de recherche en tant
que domaine de formation en tant que
domaine de recrutement d'un certain
nombre de professionnels d'organisations
y compris à l'échelle territoriale etc
c'est de très loin la seule question des
agences sanitaires et de leur rôle de
surveillance d'animation des expertises
scientifiques
voilà je m'arrête là mais c'est un point
que ce constat vous guider dans vos
analyses
ce constat malheureusement nous avons
vous et avec vous nous avons dû faire
avec c'est à dire que nous avons dû
essayer d'imaginer des stratégies
politiques ou en fonction des moyens en
fonctions en fonction des moyens que
notre pays a constitué constitue pas en
deux ans ce type d'action que notre pays
a constitué depuis quelques décennies
et voilà donc je pense que c'est
l'ampleur de cette de cette épidémie et
de cette crise doit nous appelait aussi
à engager en direction de fonds dans le
renforcement de ses signifiants diction
200 synthétique profession jugée presque
écouter sur une communication sur
l'outre-mer on a rendu deux avis dont
l'un des dès le début avril donc c'est
je me souviens encore appelée même
girardin pour pourvoir avec elle comme
on et comment monter la réponse en
outre-mer et une ré une réunion
téléphonique qui s'était pas en vidéo
qui s'étaient montés avec l'ensemble des
préfets et des directeurs des ars des
outre-mer ou au ministère d outre-mer et
il ya eu un deuxième avis ensuite sur le
déconfinement d'outre-mer et le problème
des frontières
enfin je veux dire cela on l'a pour nous
c'était vraiment à l'agenda de
l'ensemble et de ce qui a pu se passer
par ailleurs simon a beaucoup travaillé
sur les modèles pour la réponse en
guyane au moment de
de fin juillet/début août il a été très
impliqué sur les sur les modèles de
construction et de réponses qui pouvait
être donné en guyane qui au passage est
un élément positif dans tout ce parce
que ça montre que à la fois la guyane et
ce qui a pu se passer en mayenne par
exemple montrent que quand on cerne bien
les questions qu'on pose bien sûr la
table avec le territoire une série de
mesures qui sont à prendre
on peut être efficace je veux dire il
faut pas être perdant permanence et il
faut savoir reprendre la main et on peut
parfaitement le faire donc c'est quelque
chose qui peut parfaitement se
travailler même même si je reconnais que
c'est pas facile pour les populations
qui sont qui est en qui on était sûr
curité sur place survie' avait une
question sur la recherche en immunologie
oui bien sûr vous imaginez que la
réponse immunitaire des sujets qui ont
fait la queue vide fait l'objet de
beaucoup d'études
elle fait même l'objet d'essais
thérapeutiques pour regarder si les
anticorps issu des patients convalescent
pourrait aider à guérir entre guillemets
les et à réduire la sévérité des formes
graves et il ya un essai qui est menée
en france il ya des données qui sont
sortis également en italie aux états
unis et ça permet d'anticiper un peu ce
que peut être une réponse vaccinale
comme je dirais marqueurs prédictifs
haut niveau au niveau immunologique donc
oui à votre question il ya plein de
choses qui se font
la notion d'incertitude oui c'est vrai
que probablement mais c'est vous qui le
dites c'est vous qu'êtes politique de
dire que le politique et vit avec
incertitude
je ne sais pas moi de le dire moi je dis
ce que la communauté scientifique vie
avec l'incertitude mais raison plus si
l'incertitude vie si le politique vit
avec un peu d'incertitude comme on fait
rejoindre deux forme d'incertitude et
c'est bien là et c'est bien là la
complexité du dialogue un mêmes etc etc
et à mon avis tout à fait faisable et ça
pose toute la question de finalement
d'une réflexion de la réponse aux crises
et c'est la question que vous posiez qui
à mes yeux
s'ils devaient se monter une structure
et une nouvelle agence entre guillemets
ou un machin à la française ne devrait
pas être uniquement confiné aux crises
sanitaires
il devrait y avoir une réflexion plus
globale de la capacité d'un certain
nombre de gens à raisonner à froid sur
la réponse à la crise chacun
on le voit bien probablement plus que
notre génération enfin ma génération est
une génération bénie des dieux qui est
qui qui a eu 40 ans devant elle
finalement avec eux avec et des aspects
extrêmement positive où je comprends la
jeunesse actuelle qui dit mais après
tout vous avez vécu une vie
extraordinaire
laissez nous vivre là maintenant et vous
confient des points c'est quand même ça
qu'on entend un tout petit peu un dans
une certaine mesure
eh bien je dis que on est depuis
maintenant une quand on regarde entre
les crises économiques
les crises sanitaires on est dans des
enjeux de crises successives et
probablement il ya une certaine forme de
professionnalisation et de capacité de
sur le plan multidisciplinaire a réponse
à ces crises et qui doit être à côté du
politique c'est le politique qui doit
décider bien sûr toujours mais qui doit
être capable de lui fournir de
l'information de la réponse aux crises
et un certain nombre de modalités
d'information donc sur la sueur faut-il
créer une agence j'en sais rien je par
contre je rejoins totalement ce qu'a dit
daniel en termes sanitaires ce qui sort
de cette crise c'est le problème
finalement d'une réorganisation de la
santé publique en france
et je vous rappelle que ça ça va très
loin c'est à dire que si je regarde le
modèle anglo saxon modèle allemand c'est
reprenons les pays comme un tout petit
peu mieux réussi que nous si je peux
dire la santé publique n'est pas
intégrée à la santé il ya des facultés
de santé publique qui sont dehors des
facultés de médecine et donc ça va très
loin dans la formation il n'y a pas
besoin d'être médecin pour faire
forcément de la santé publique il ya des
formations en sciences po actuellement
ou des formations à l'essec
la demande être rassemblé et
probablement avoir une nouvelle vision
de la santé publique et on avait été
assez loin puisque quelques-uns d'entre
nous c'est on souhaitait même que se
constitue finalement une sorte de
secrétariat d'état à la santé publique
qui ne soit pas rattachée au ministère
de la santé mais rattaché à matignon
tafer mais le sénat travaille sur
différentes hypothèses en aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir
merci pour les réponses nous allons
passer à la deuxième salve je vous
demande plus que jamais d'être concis
car il ya une troisième salve et
laurence cohen un oui merci monsieur le
président merci aux interventions des
banques du comité scientifique et
monsieur delfraissy alors moi je vais
essayer d'être à petit quatre questions
on entend on entend parler de la
mutation du virus qui fait dire à
certains que peut-être qu'il serait
moins moins actifs moins dangereux et
c'est donc j'aimerais avoir des
précisions là dessus en sachant qu'il
est toujours difficile effectivement
d'avoir une information qui soit
effectivement étayé qui n'entraîne pas
un surcroît de peur à la fois donc qui
alerte mais sans en rajouter
or on voit que c'est compliqué le rôle
des médias là dessus est aussi assez
difficile et j'aimerais avoir votre
sentiment parce que comme tout
parlementaire je pense qu on a on a fait
en cette rentrée le tour des écoles et
j'ai trouvé les directions d'école en
tout cas de ma ville extrêmement
inquiète parce qu'elles ne savent pas
quoi faire face à des enfants qui ce qui
va c'est naturel on est qui coule tous
etc
les rhumes voilà et c'était assez
frappant certaines directrice tout de
suite alertant les médecins donc tout de
suite des tests ou de suites etc et
d'autres disant bon bah on va attendre
un peu mais en tout cas complètement
désemparé donc quel est ce que là vous
avez en tant que comité scientifique des
recommandations qui
peuvent aider ces professionnels
deuxième deuxième question vous avez
recommandé effectivement une protection
je vais le dire pour aller vite par
rapport à un certain nombre de deux
personnes fragiles et notamment face à
certaines pathologies
est-ce que vous ne trouvez pas que sa
rente en totale contradiction avec le
décret qui a été pris et qui exclut donc
des personnes fragiles un certain nombre
de pathologies je pense à elle l'obésité
etc pour les leurs les contraindre à ne
pas aller travailler et ne pas pratiquer
le télétravail 3e troisième question
vous avez dit que effectivement il ya
besoin de revisiter c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
le notre système de santé or nous avons
été alertés lors de nos différentes
auditions par le fait que pendant toute
la crise aiguë de l'aco vide
il ya eu beaucoup de déprogrammation de
d'opération il ya eu beaucoup aussi de
renoncement aux soins par peur et il
semblerait que la com ont à nouveau une
à dire une reprise je sais pas si ça
arrêtez de delà de la pandémie est ce
qu'on n'a pas un risque de déprogrammer
à nouveau des des opérations et qui
mettent la vie des personnes en danger
enfin la dernière la dernière question
vous avez parlé des vaccins un petit peu
des traitements moi j'ai été quand même
frappé par le fait que vous avez dit
qu'il y avait une modification de la
stratégie et que les laboratoires ont
sont en première ligne est ce que vous
ne pensez pas justement que les
différences d état se trouve un peu
pieds et poings liés par rapport aux
politiques des grands labos et est-ce
que ça n'est pas le moment de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait un
comment dirais-je un grand pôle public
du médicament et de la recherche pour
développer un certain nombre de
médicaments et éventuellement également
des vaccins
merci angèle préville merci monsieur le
président alors je vais d'abord
reprendre une des dernières
interventions du professeur delfraissy
parce que c'est la question que je
voulais lui poser justement et pour pour
évoquer le fait que dans certains pays
il existe des instances scientifiques
qui sont attachés au gouvernement et qui
permettent d'avoir une grande réactivité
puisque je les ai rencontrés dans le
cadre de l'opex notamment à je suis je
pense que ça s'appelle comme ça le
scientifique en chef à québec au québec
donc c'est dans les pays anglo-saxons et
donc évidemment parce que moi je serais
pour qu'on mette en place ce genre de
choses c'est à dire d'avoir un
scientifique en chef ou pas et qu'on ait
autour de lui papa des gens qui soient
en permanence là mais toute une liste de
scientifiques qu'on pourrait mettre à
contribution puisque comme vous l'avez
dit on a certainement dans l'avenir on
va espérer que non mais on va devoir
faire face à des crises différentes qui
devront mobiliser des scientifiques
différents des géologues des chimistes
des physiciens et c'est donc voilà
est-ce que vous pensez que ce serait une
bonne chose de faire est en quelque
sorte puisque je n'aime pas trop
l'appeler comme ça mais cultiver une
espèce de culture du risque qui est
manque un peu peut-être dans notre pays
alors ma deuxième question va au sujet
des ehpad
alors vous avez émis un regret 2
vous avez dit ne pas vouloir recommencer
est-ce que ce regret c'est sûr là
quelque part sur la faute d'humanité par
rapport aux personnes âgées
est ce que parce que moi j'ai eu dans
mon entourage une personne âgée de kim
est très proche de 84 ans qui m'a dit
que de toute façon si c'était de lui
interdire à près de sortir etc ne le
ferai pas elle ne voudrait pas le faire
et qu'elle avait lavé qualité tout à
fait capable de choisir celles se
mettait en danger ou pas parce qu'elle
vit via la maison affiche est celle donc
voilà qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
chute de ce que je viens de vous dire
et enfin effectivement la santé publique
a subi ces dernières années une logique
comptable et moi je m'interrogeais sur
les nombre de lits en réanimation
actuellement parce que vous vous avez
tous dit que en allemagne la réussite
était meilleur parce que et que
notamment il y avait plus de lits de
réanimation par rapport au nombre
d'habitants
mais est-ce qu'on a changé ceci nous
depuis le mois de mars et est ce que ça
faisait partie de vous de vos conseils
de d'augmenter les lits et moi j'ai cru
entendre hier ou avant-hier un
urgentiste je prends je sais plus un
médecin dire qu'en fait rien n'avait
changé et qu'on avait toujours le même
nombre de lits de réanimation voit la
journée merci martin lévriers merci
monsieur le président merci professeur
es et merci à tous les membres du
conseil scientifique
quatre questions rapides la première le
30 octobre c'est demain c'est le genre
la salle bien venu d'ailleurs donc
faut-il redire bienvenue au conseil tel
qu'il est ou avez vous des pistes
d'amélioration pour ce conseil si
nécessaire deuxième question vous avez
parlé aussi de la presse avec son effet
lupo voir son effet déformant des à cela
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que le
conseil a bien communiqué en tenant
compte de ces éléments là où faut-il là
aussi améliorer la communication du
conseil par rapport à la presse
troisième question il ya eu un grand
débat en france je le résume je ne suis
pas scientifique médecin mais entre une
méthode empirique proposée par certains
et puis les méthodes classiques mais
autre récente avec le double aveugle
avec etc
cette controverse est devenu un
véritable combat en france
qui a angoissé beaucoup de français
d'ailleurs ne faut-il pas en tant que
scientifique que vous repreniez tous le
chemin de la discussion pour éviter ce
genre de combat qui ne nuisent en fait à
une bonne communication et qui inquiète
les français et pour des médecins c'est
toujours embêtant d'inquiéter les
français les dernières questions qui
rejoint aussi la question de la même
préville sur les ehpad et sur les
maisons de santé de retraite pardon je
vais pas une question sera quasi
caricatural mais je pense qu'elle est
importante vaut-il mieux mourir du coc
vide entourée de l'amour de ses proches
ou vous teigneux mourir seul de la
solitude ou voilà c'est un pas très
important merci beaucoup
emmanuel capus mais merci monsieur le
président donc on est devant une
commission denquête donc j'ai donc
commission d enquête çà çà enquête à
charge et à décharge donc j'ai donc une
question a chargé une question à
décharge
parce que pour connaître les
améliorations il faut aussi savoir ce
qui a fonctionné
c'est une enquête
ça n'est pas elle mais je je préfère
dire l'état d'esprit dans lequel je pose
ma question
une enquête se fait à charge et à
décharge je le répète elle ne vêlent
vise les dysfonctionnements je m'exprime
différemment elle vise les
dysfonctionnements et elle vise aussi
les bon fonctionnement
voilà je vais trouver un accord avec mes
collègues donc dans les 10 dans les
dysfonctionnements
il me semble monsieur le président que
la position du comité scientifique a
évolué au fil des mois sur l'usagé du
masque
c'est une question que nous avons eu
beaucoup dans les mois qui sont qui ont
passé la question est extrêmement simple
est-ce que la position et les
recommandations du comité scientifique a
évolué en fonction de l'état du stock de
masques dans le pays ou pas très
concrètement est ce que quand il n'y
avait pas de masque
le comité scientifique recommandait ne
recommandait pas leur usage est
maintenant qu'il y en a le comité
scientifique
recommandent-ils leur usage voilà c'est
ma première question vous avez compris
que c'était plutôt la question à sa
charge une question plutôt à décharge
sur les bon fonctionnement président
savary a dit que le système français
l'été n'était pas prêt n'avait pas
réussi à faire face et vous avez accès
s'est cependant quand on se regarde
forcément on se désole alors j'ai
karoutchi tout à l'heure à 10 40 mille
morts c'est extrêmement dramatique mais
quant au second quand on se compare on
se console
vous avez parlé de la situation de
l'allemagne avec le cas particulier du
cas de mulhouse
et puis sans doute une préparation du
système sanitaire et une mentalité
différente du peuple français mais il y
a aussi dans notre entourage immédiat je
parle pas des situations avec des
régimes politiques différents dans notre
entourage immédiat des pays comme
l'italie l'espagne la le royaume uni
dont le système sanitaire semble avoir
été submergé ce qui n'a pas été notre
cas
donc ma question au titre des choses qui
ont bien fonctionné c'est qu'est ce qui
a permis bien que nous ne soyons pas
prêts à faire face à cette crise de
mieux gérer la crise que l'espagne que
l'italie ou que le royaume uni merci
céline boulay espérons merci monsieur le
président trois questions rapidement
monsieur le professeur delfraissy
vous avez dit j'aurais parié sur une
immunité de 20 à 25% de la population
à quel moment avez vous pariez sur cette
immunité puisqu'à partir du moment où la
population était confiné il me semble
que cette immunité de 20 à 25% été
rendue impossible
donc j'aurais voulu un peu plus de
précision là dessus
deuxièmement il ya tjrs et d'autres
conseils scientifiques tel que le nôtre
en france ratifié par le parlement et
pour aider à les décisions politiques
s'appelle-t-il comme ça dans les autres
pays européens y at il une harmonisation
à ce que vous échangez avec eux il me
semble que notre collègue angèle prive
il a fait référence à des systèmes
équivalents dans les pays anglo-saxons
et puis si pour des cures puisqu'on est
dans la gestion de crise pour des crises
futur des constitutions de conseil
scientifique avec une harmonisation
européen serait souhaitable
et enfin troisième question vous avez
dit que vous n'étiez pas une structure
pérenne et que vous étiez amené à être
dissous si j'ai bien compris le 30
octobre
mais pour autant j'ai bien compris que
vous entendiez peser sur un débat de
fond sur les politiques publiques en
matière de santé et pour cause puisque
l' expertise que vous aurez acquises
pendant cette crise va être pérenne et
va être précieuse donc de quelle manière
comptez-vous peser sur la réorganisation
de la santé publique en france
je remercie merci et écoutez là que de
la matière dix minutes 10 minutes de
réponse globale pour laisser place
ensuite aux autres intervenants et à
leurs questions si vous le voulez bien
je suis désolé mais je comprends ces
deux d'autres pourront répondre aussi
chaud que denis abandonné que tu puisse
prendre la parole écoutée sur sur
mutations non à ma connaissance
le studio s'est énormément étudiée au
niveau mondial dans énormément de
laboratoire il y à de multiples petites
mutations qui existe une un peu plus
importante s y at il une mutation
actuelle qui pourrait expliquer par
exemple ne il n'y a aucune preuve
actuelle et il n'y a pas de mutation
décrite de ce virus de façon
significative dans les dents les grands
labos internationale sur
[Musique]
l'incompatibilité un peu entre le décret
du 29 août qui restreint finalement les
niveaux des pathologies et sur les
patients les plus fragiles et le message
actuel qui est de dire pour les patients
les plus fragiles
attention ce sont eux il faut pouvoir
les ans entre guillemets des les
protéger oui il ya quelque chose qui
était un peu incohérent et que nous
avons signalé d'ailleurs aux autorités
de santé et que ce décret du 29 août
tombée très mal compte tenu d'une
certaine forme de reprise de l'épidémie
sur les patients que vides moi j'ai déjà
j'ai déjà pris la parole la suge
pourrait revenir ou cesse et la balance
tout le monde début mars
on sait qu'aux patients commise plus
fine appelons un chat un chat et c'était
et nous mêmes nous avions d'emblée dit
qu' il y aurait il fallait faire très
attention et qu'ils avaient une
morbidité induites chez les patients que
vis de moi
il ya aussi d'ailleurs eu des
améliorations il ya eu moins d'accidents
de voiture il y ait moins de ya eu moins
de deux traumatismes de fracture du col
du fémur chez les personnes âgées des
bons et donc il ya en effet 7 7
c'était qui livre a trouvé très
clairement l'équilibré là maintenant
pour septembre octobre novembre pour les
quatre mois qui viennent il doit se
faire en une partie pour le que vie de
plus et une très large partie pour les
patients que vides - on est tous
persuadés et j'ai indiqué des chiffres
de réanimation à cet égard et mais
comment on va faire et comment on va
faire et c'est bien là la difficulté
d'essayer d'éviter que de nouveaux le
système de réanimation soit en tension
c'est c'est bien le le point est-ce que
qu'est ce que j'avais d'autres sur les
laboratoires les vaccins et finalement
la relation entre les états et les
industriels
écoutez moi je suis de ceux qui pensent
que que l'industrie pharmaceutique à une
place trop dominante dans notre modèle
de santé le comme le comité national
d'éthique ce choix doit sortir un avis
sur le sujet dans les semaines qui
viennent sur les coûts faramineux de
l'accès à l'innovation donc gg aucun
état d'âme là dessus ce qui a été
demandé est demandée par notre président
est que le vaccin que vides soit
considérée comme un bien public mondial
et il a beaucoup insisté là-dessus
auprès de l'ensemble des chefs d'état et
qu'on arrive à des coûts de l'ordre des
propositions de coûts de l'ordre de
quelques dollars
le vaccin à visée militaire
je laissais passer on compare avec cette
base d'arm 6 1 qui est quand même très
particulier sur les sur les la culture
du risque je crois qu'on sait déjà qu'on
s'est déjà exprimée la question vous
posiez cette finalement compte tenu de
l'expérience d'un comité scientifique
auprès du plus haut niveau politique
est-ce qu'il faut finalement
indépendamment de qu'ovide réfléchir sur
ce qu'on met en france et qu'on
construise un comité scientifique auprès
du président de la république du premier
ministre et c'est une vraie question
je vais vous dire c'est une vraie
question
moi je demande jeudi joker pour pour
aller plus loin dans la réflexion mais
c'est une vraie question
ce n est pas facile parce que un comité
scientifique doit pas être seulement
dans le sanitaire
il doit être dans une vision plus
globale on alopexx qui est qu'ils jouent
pas totalement ce rôle là par rapport à
d'autres pays on n'a pas cette structure
un tout petit peu indépendante j'insiste
sur ce caractère deux à la fois de
dialogue avec le politique mais
d'indépendance aussi il faut des gens de
vraiment de bon niveau qui a envie de
donner aussi et qu'ils soient pas
seulement dans dans dans nos facs et
envie de donner pour la nation quand on
rentre dans dans dans ce type de comités
mais c'est une vraie question et je
pense qu'il faudra dont le poste qu vide
mais on est encore trop tôt là me
semble-t-il mais se poser la question
que légitimement les parlementaires se
pose cette question
je rappelle que ça c'est fait aux etats
unis pendant une période qu'il en
angleterre qui l'ont qu'ils l'ont japon
dans les dents des très grandes
démocraties et puis il ya les pays qui
ne l'ont pas par contre sur les ai pas
de que denis tu veux redire un petit mot
sur les ehpad peut-être est-ce que tu
l'as vécu toit de près je rejoins les
accents relatifs à la culture de la
médecine préventive qui nous reste
encore à approprié et quand on voit le
visage les ehpad il y a eu des des
espaces où les choses ont été gérés on
va dire je ne dirais pas favorable mais
en tout cas dans une situation moins
défavorable s'il s'agissait de des pâtes
qui s'était engagé en l'occurrence à sur
un échiquier de un ou deux ans
auparavant à des programmes d'éducation
sanitaire de formation de leur personnel
de de mobilisation des ressources
d'hygiène de construction au niveau des
territoires du bénéfice des clips mobile
qui pouvait être partagée avec la
médecine ambulatoire en général
des équipes des plateformes adossé aux
états aux établissements de santé
fusse-t-il universitaire ou non et ça
c'est un c'est un recours qui qui a été
qui a été bénéfique au jour on on
commence à faire le constat de l'impact
de l'aco vide au niveau des ehpad
ensuite en effet nous sommes sur un
équilibre qui est qui est essentiel
difficile mais qu'il nous faut conquérir
entre le fait que les ehpad sont devenus
souvent des noms plus des lieux entre
guillemets de retraite mais des espaces
de santé alors qu'il ne l'était pas à
bini sio et où on vient chercher du soin
avec des niveaux de mobilisation de
ressources humaines qui ne sont pas
toujours au à ce rendez vous et tout
cela avec au jour d'aujourd'hui une
durée de vie dans ces établissements
pour les résidants d'une médiane de
trois ans ça il faut que nous en ayons
aussi la mesures de qu'est ce que nous
voulons faire de nos ehpad à la faveur
de cette expérience cruciale et à l'aune
de deux sauts de soin du visage de sa
fréquentation et là au jour
d'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans l'
équilibre entre l'obligation de la
relation en effet on ne peut pas rompre
protéger nos aînés ne veut pas dire les
isolés ne veut pas dire rompre la
relation avec leur famille s'ils en ont
encore également avec la proximité qui
dont ils jouissent avec le personnel qui
les entoure et et le fait que le les
mesures accompagnant les visiteurs qui
doivent être maintenus doivent rendre
compte de la de la minimalisation et de
la de la tendance vers 02 du risque de
transmission donc c'est un équilibre qui
est compliqué mais c'est un équilibre
est essentielle et c'est l'enjeu 2-2
peut-être de ce jour d'après crucial
pour préserver nos aînés la culture
l'obligation de la relation et de les
préserver et pour eux et aussi pour que
pour que pour que le risque d'atteinte
par sept par cette virose et avantages
alors à cette eau il ya plusieurs
questions c'est un patient qu'ovide dans
ce type d'établissement pouvons-nous
nous accorder les moyens de le conserver
sur site surtout s'il y a un espace de
relations avec les équipes qui le
prennent en charge
et aussi son son voisinage de même ne
serait ce que l'espace et c'est que
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
éminemment creuser et puis aussi trouver
des structures intermédiaires entre
l'hospitalisation obligatoire dans des
conditions qui sont coûteuses au niveau
humain est aussi en termes de rendement
avec des structures intermédiaires de
type structure de de gériatrie de
proximité ambulatoire il ya un espace
que beaucoup de régions beaucoup de
territoires se sont approprié à ce sujet
et qui peuvent être à l'heure de haller
des recommandations et et de l'arrêt de
l'accès dans cette période de reprise
épidémique
je vous remercie pour la suite des
réponses à charge entre guillemets un
jeu je reprends vos mois et mais je ne
le vis pas comme tu te sois charge et à
décharge
est-ce que les la position du conseil
scientifique sur les masses pont on a
fait le constat sur notre sort on en a
parlé dès le début on a fait constat qu'
il n'y avait pas de masque et que les
masses qui te qui étaient disponibles
devaient être utilisés en priorité pour
les soignants puisque c'est là où il y
avait le risque qui était le plus
important est ensuite donc que c'était
notre et notre notre nos propositions
ont tenu compte de la réalité en effet
de la capacité à voir les masques mais
on le 10 ans c'est à dire qu'en dix ans
on n'a pas les bases et à qui on
consacre les masques nous avons ensuite
dans un deuxième temps vous savez qui a
sont apparus doucement les masques etc
je reviens pas on avait je le rappelle
aucun rôle opérationnel sur la sur la la
commande de masques un personnellement
je
je pense que on aurait dû probablement
pu faire plus appel à une série de
structures privées ou ba hmad de grandes
ong ou qui ont des capacités
opérationnelles qui qui sont qui aurait
pu être utilisé peut-être de façon
optimale ensuite vous avez vu qu'il y
avait une évolution y compris
scientifiques sur l'intérêt du port du
masque et qu'on a réussi avec d'autres
d'autres comités d'ailleurs
internationaux a à construire et avec
l'ol masqué mais elle même relevé sur
finalement le masque mal un outil
additionnel pour à la fois protéger les
autres et et se protéger donc c'est
cindy double chose pour répondre à votre
question est très franc et vous voyez
d'ailleurs dans les tons a repris le mot
masque dans nos avis on a vu nous mêmes
notre évolution 1er mai qui tient compte
de la réalité du nombre de masse et
aussi de ce qu'on attendait du mas par
rapport aux gouttelettes virus alors
mieux géré que ukc espagne et que et que
italie d'abord les italiens sont bien
gérées parce qu'ils sont trouvés en
première ligne vraiment et regardez où
ils sont maintenant ils sont à un niveau
de circulation virale qui est qui et qui
est beaucoup plus faible que nous donc
les comparaisons je dois dire elles sont
il faut attendre encore un tout petit
peu uk iuk et ils ont eu beaucoup de
chance je vais vous dire que leur
premier ministre soient atteints du coc
vide parce que il était totalement
destinée et pépé venant je suis désolé
de dire ça devant le devant les
autorités de l'état mais enfin il faut
appeler un chat un chat à certains
moments et il était parti comme
probablement le président américain
et puis ça fait vraiment peur et il ya
eu un retour en arrière sur la position
sur la position en angleterre mais on
voit bien ça illustre très bien et simon
pourrait vous l'expliqué en détail
comment une décision qui est retardée de
huit ou dix jours par rapport à un temps
donné de l'épidémie dans une épidémie ou
la courbe qui monte n'est pas une n'est
pas une courbe nul
je dirais études courbe exponentielle et
comment ça peut faire très bas et donc
ça explique la position la position
anglaise sur la position espagnole
c'est plus compliqué parce que il faut
bien voir que les éléments de réponse et
de comparaisons ne sont pas finis c'est
à dire qui on a on est là en train de
regarder ce qui s'est passé dans la
première période mais qu'est ce qui va
se passer dans la deuxième période est
sûre et sur le moyen long terme
et puis sur les conséquences également
je dirais alors que vite tel qu'on l'a
vu donc je pense que la france va s'en
sortir
finalement pas si mal et en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on souhaite évidemment tous
et probablement parce que on a un
système de soins hospitaliers qui est un
système qui est assez extraordinaire
quand il répond à l'urgence
moi je vais toujours vécu comme tel et
on est vieux c'est qu'on était déjà dans
une crise hospitalière lourds avants
avancent à en raison des contraintes
budgétaires qui se sont qui se sont mis
sur l'hôpital depuis longtemps mais
l'hôpital a une capacité des soignants
français à pouvoir répondre
ils l'ont fait une fois je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il puisse le faire une deuxième
fois
ils sont il ya une fatigue générale
il ya une lassitude les services de
réanimation nous indique tout ce qu'ils
ont du mal pour le personnel à recruter
il faut faire très attention à ça que
cet exemple extraordinaire qui s'est
produit en mars avril il y aura une
grande difficulté si on avait besoin de
revenir à des choses difficiles et à ce
que le modèle hospitalier répondait même
façon et c'est pour ça qu'on dit
attention prévenons ne nous retrouvons
pas dans le même type de situation
écoutez je crois que les lignes et une
dimension européenne et les autres pays
européens oui on a on a eu comme je l'aï
indiqué au début on a été on ait eu des
contacts peut être pas suffisamment et
j'ai indiqué qu'il n'y avait pas
d'harmonisation dans les décisions et
que c'était une certaine forme de
faillite de l'europe jusque et je peux
le comprendre
au départ je le comprends moi maintenant
par exemple qu'il n'y ait pas de
décisions plus partagés entre guy
mais sur la reprise et des outils à
utiliser en cas de reprise de l'épidémie
sur l'immunité de population oui je vous
ai dit que c'était ma vision en janvier
1 2 j'aurais dit qu'on arriverait
probablement à 25 cents 1,2 parce que je
pensais que il y aurait il y aurait une
immunité qui serait qui serait beaucoup
plus active
mais comme tout le monde j'ai rien à
regarder les chiffres et vous avez un
très très beau papier de mon voisin dans
un très grand journal d'immunologie avec
eux avec arnaud il il ya une semaine et
qui explique bien ce qu'a été l'immunité
en population et comment elle se
construit et puis on a les chiffres
devant nous qui qui sont entre 5 et 10%
dont je regarde en m'appuyant sur les
faits scientifiques quant à votre
dissolution du 30 octobre
écoutez martin moi j'ai envie de me
répondent qu'elle est entre vos mains
1 que vous dire de plus on avait on
avait souhaité je dirais disparaître le
12 juillet bon on est en pleine
discussion nous même de savoir ce qu il
faut t'il ou pas poursuivre et que
mettez-vous notre place entre guillemets
c'est ça finit quand même par prendre
beaucoup beaucoup de temps et c'est une
pression comme qui est très important
que vous en rendez compte y compris les
médias en face et c'est une très lourde
très lourde pression bon al'inverse
question posée c'est la première
question qui nous a été posée
oui mais s'il ya plus de conseils
scientifiques qui qui est là pour
conseiller d'entre eux y met alors ça
peut être aussi un conseil scientifique
renouveler ou changer
en dignité pour répondre eh ben je crois
avoir répondu c'est en disant que
c'était une pure hypothèse de ma part
qui est très vite détruit devant devant
les chiffres la réalité
j'ai très rapidement van hamme préville
et monsieur martin mais très très
rapidement un oui je n'ai pas eu la
réponse sur le nombre de lits de
réanimation alors le nombre de lits de
réa a été très accentuée au moment du
mois de mars selon les régions
évidemment des régions touchées le
nombre de lits de rehamna vais pas
doubler comme comme non comme on a pu
voir dans certaines régions il a
rebaissé ensuite parce que il y avait du
personnel qui je vous le rappelle en
région parisienne venaient d'autres
régions de france qui est venu aider les
réanimations effet retourner les lits et
le problème n'est pas tellement le
matériel ce n'est pas tellement les
respirateurs ce n'est pas tellement
c'est surtout maintenant problèmes de
personnel donc le nombre de l'île de ré
à part rapport je dirais ou au 1er
février reste plus élevé et on voit bien
comment marseille par exemple a pu
immédiatement augmenter son nombre de
lits dans en fin de semaine ou en début
de cette semaine
il ya cette capacité d'augmentation des
lits qui demeure mais ensuite pour quel
type de patients et c'est là l'enjeu
c'est qu'on ne reviendra pas et on ne
pourra pas revenir à 90% des leaders et
à consacrer aux patients que vite plus
il faut vraiment être persuadé de sa et
de se dire donc il faut fermer entre
guillemets et limiter au maximum
l'arrivée des patients en réanimation
pour pas se trouver dans une situation
éthique extrêmement délicate
merci un mot martin oui si vous le
présente juste de questions j'avais posé
j'ai pas entendu la réponse l'effet
loupe de la presse c'est votre
communication avec la rapidement papa
rapidement l approche scientifique qui
passe de la controverse au combat
comment revenir en arrière et l'empêcher
merci alors sur la presse on a on avait
comme comme c'est une structure légère
mais peut-être à tort certains au niveau
du monde du conseil scientifique qui
était parti
ils ont dû ne de quelque chose de
beaucoup plus professionnelle on nous
étions accompagnés par une chargée de
communication très professionnelle par
ailleurs que que j'avais que le wiki
j'avais eu l'occasion de travailler et
nous avons décidé de communiquer
essentielle ment à l'occasion de nos
avis de décès de ne pas communiquer et
de ne pas commenter les décisions
gouvernementales
et puis de temps en temps vous savez on
se fait piéger sur un mot au tout d'un
coup vous allumez la presse et j'en suis
un bon exemple récent quand j'ai dit des
mesures difficiles difficile à élaborer
apprendre je voulais dire pas forcément
qu'elle allait être très dur donc
c'était c'était assez clair et je
l'avais dit d'ailleurs donc ensuite on a
on a par exemple on n'a pas mis de
compte twitter on n'est pas rentré du
tout dans les réseaux sociaux et c'est
une jeu considéré que ce n'était pas le
rôle du conseil scientifique de rentrer
dedans une dans ce type de stratégie et
je ne le regrette pas elle a ensuite une
fois de plus on en est on était parti
sur quelque chose d'un peu provisoire
prolongation s'il se montaient pas papa
pour nous j'entends mes dents dans une
vision future d'un comité scientifique
auprès des débuts du président de la
république ou du premier ministre sur
une perspective de plusieurs années je
dépasse que vides il faudrait
probablement là qui est une vraie
réflexion de construction avec la presse
pour pour le faire
là nous on a on a fait quelque chose je
dirais de communiqué les membres du
conseil scientifique ont par ailleurs
leur vie propre et ils peuvent
communiquer à titre individuel parce que
ce sont des scientifiques qui peuvent
éclairer les populations et ils le font
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux donc
c'est un équilibre qu on a essayé de
trouver
voilà est votre dernière question
c'était sûr toujours la controverse
lala examen qu'on doit écouter mais je
pense vraiment si vous reprenez ce qu'on
a écrit et ce qu'on a
est ce qu'on a dit nous ne sommes pas du
tout rentrer dans cette compte
et à titre personnel alors j'aurais pu
très bien le faire je ne suis pas du
tout rentrer dans sept contrôleurs et je
ne souhaite pas y rentrer encore
maintenant la seule indication une fois
de plus le comité scientifique vous avez
très bien signalé monsieur le président
il y avait un comité caire qui
s'occupait des questions de recherche et
en particulier des aspects
thérapeutiques les aspects
thérapeutiques était évidemment
important en terme y compris de
décisions de santé publique
notre premier avis sur les résultats des
différents essais il date de fin juillet
et ils s'appuient sur les résultats des
essais randomisés et sinon nous ne
sommes absolument pas rentrer dans la
controverse
alors il reste encore quatre
intervenants véronique guillotin merci à
monsieur le président voilà ça va aller
relativement vite puisqu'une bonne
partie des questions étaient posées la
première c'était sur la communication je
pense que çà çà çà traumatisa a
traumatisé un bon nombre de nos
concitoyennes communication qui était
qui allait en avant qui reparte en
arrière qui était quelquefois
contradictoires une communication
scientifique une comédie d'une
communication politique
donc ma question était mais vous y avez
assez répondu c est ce qu il n'y a pas
un moyen effectivement de retravailler
sur cette communication pour en
situation de crise notamment et de crise
assez grave on apaise nos concitoyens
plutôt qu'on amène qu'on amène de la
controverse de la polémique ou des
choses non comprises peut-être parce
qu'on amène pas de la polémique voilà
c'est plutôt la non compréhension de
cette de ce que vous avez appelé
peut-être les incertitudes scientifiques
essentielles ou en tout cas nécessaire
ma deuxième question c'est est là qu'ils
ont sur les masques et la communication
scientifique sur les masques je suis
médecin de profession et dans les études
médicales enfin
lorsque l'on est médecin on sait bien
que le masque sert à protéger et on
avait l'impression que la copie que la
commune de la communauté scientifique ne
savait plus à quoi devait servir un
masque si elle servait à quelque chose
ou pas quel masque on devait utiliser ou
pas le masque en tissu ne servait à rien
après ils servent à quelque chose
mais même moi j'avoue avoir été un petit
peu perdues et balancé dans ses
certitudes donc la question a été posée
est-ce que les réponses ont été faites
en fonction d'un manque en fait de
masquer dans notre pays
ou est-ce que c'était des restes des
questions purement scientifique et j'ai
la même question sur les tests on a peu
testé l'allemagne à beaucoup tester on
est un pays très frontalier de
l'allemagne comment est il possible que
l'on n'ait pas eu un moment une
communication claire sur les tests on
devrait tester mans ne peut pas pour
telle ou telle raison
ou est ce que l'on ne savait pas à ce
moment là que le test était utile matrot
dernière question c'est sur la virulence
donc j'ai entendu que vous avez dit que
la virulence semblait être la même entre
virus du mois de mars est celui que l'on
connaît actuellement
donc si la virulence et la même cela
voudrait dire que le nombre de patients
contaminés en mars était beaucoup plus
important que ce qu'on a pu l'imaginer
puisque le nombre de patients rey a été
décuplé par rapport à celui ci donc
qu'est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas sur des
territoires à une immunisation de groupe
sur certains territoires comme le grand
est par exemple puisque on a eu
tellement de patients hospitalisés donc
normalement beaucoup de patients qui ont
rencontré le virus
ouais ça c'était ma question et je
m'arrêterai là puisque le reste a été
grandement merci de même souligné merci
monsieur présent j'ai j'écoutais
l'ensemble et puis on est dans une
commission denquête un peu inédite
puisque on n'est pas en train seulement
de regarder ce qui s'est passé
sereinement mais c'est en train de se
passer nous sommes en pleine crise et
donc on est aussi regarder attendu pour
des réponses immédiates de vie
quotidienne pour éclairer les citoyens
je relève que monsieur karoutchi a parlé
qu'il y avait des pays qui réussissaient
mieux et il a cité les pays autoritaires
bien entendu personne va faire le choix
de ce type de régime pour répondre à la
pandémie et mais l'autorité est une
chose très importante quand il ya une
crise quand il ya une crise les citoyens
attentes de l'autorité des messages
parce que la confiance doit être très
grande pour pouvoir tenir ensemble
or a été évoqué le moment où on a le
sentiment que l'autorité politique
adapte la réalité à ses moyens il n'y a
pas de masque et on explique on explique
c'était quand même expliqué à la télé
par des porte parole gouvernementaux que
le masque ne savait rien voire même
qu'il était dangereux
si le grand public le porter et le
portait mal vous nous confirmer que
jamais le comité scientifique n'a pu
éclairer puisque c'était son rôle
l'autorité politique pour qu'il dise ça
donc c'était politique au sens le plus
cru d'avoir émis cela c'était pour des
raisons même politicienne et maintenant
nous sommes dans une autre situation
qu'on vit tous les jours où enfin on
disait il y a une stratégie vous l'avez
résumé par tester tester tracé isolé
donc c'est affirmer qu'il faut faire ça
on a légiféré pour donner les moyens à
l'état de faire ça sans même parler
d'applications etc numérique pour
amplifier le ce qui était possible
physiquement et manuellement
et moi je viens de vivre pendant le mois
qui s'est écoulé mais tous linverse dans
la pratique de sa stratégie c'est à dire
qu'on a affiché une stratégie mais
encore une fois on n'a ni aucun moyen et
il ya une désorientation total des
citoyens
vous l'avez pointé dans votre dernier
rapport sur cette question de la
traçabilité
j'ai assisté à une fête familiale
il y à un mois chez était évident que vu
la montée il y avait quelques restes at
his tic au moins que quelqu'un vienne
avec le virus et qui puisse y avoir un
petit problème
ça n'a pas manqué et la personne a
averti le lendemain du résultat d'un
test housse elle était positive donc
tous ceux qui avaient été informés par
sept personnes ont été se tester tout de
suite
le résultat c'est que non seulement lui
mais ce qu'ils se ont été positifs n'ont
jamais reçu un coup de fil pour leur
dire donnez nous vos contacts
heureusement qu'ils le font eux-mêmes et
que les boucles whatsapp exceptions
existent pour ça que s'appuyait sur des
citoyens éclairés ça sert d'ailleurs si
on dit c'est bon on va vous appeler vous
allez être tracé et ensuite vous serez
isolé à l'hôtel alors que ça n'existe
pas dans les faits matériels ça n'existe
pas aujourd'hui peut-être c'est mieux de
dire on n'a pas les moyens de le faire
complètement n'essaiera mais vous voilà
des outils que vous pouvez avoir pour
vous tracez et pour réagir et comment il
ya eu des situations du type on se teste
en même temps dans le couple il y en a
qui s'avère positif l'autre n'a pas le
résultat du test pendant sept jours
alors qu'ils le font en même temps et ça
s'avère négatif ou l' inverse des trucs
incroyables ou si les choses avaient été
faites
notamment pour séparer des couples etc
et leur donner les moyens de le faire
c'est à dire l'hôtel il y aurait eu
moins de dégâts mais je conclus donc
comment expliquez vous qu'on continue
avec des messages qui ne correspondent
pas aux réalités et qui enlève
l'autorité qui en démocratie est basé
que sur la crédibilité de ce qui est dit
et la pédagogie et la raison or
aujourd'hui personnes des citoyens ne
constate pas que on les teste avec des
moyens quand ils font des queues de huit
heures de 10 heures les résultats
révèlent jours après donc peu
d'efficacité et il n'ya pas d'isolement
proposé chez un seul
oui monsieur le président mes chers
collègues trois questions je vous
interroge monsieur le président
delfraissy sur les moyens qui ont été
mis à votre disposition lors de la mise
en place de ce conseil scientifique
qu'il s'agisse de moyens humains j'ai
bien compris qu'elle n'ait pas eu
beaucoup des moyens matériels bien
évidemment et puis des moyens financiers
ma deuxième question avez vous le
sentiment d'avoir été globalement
écoutés entendus dans vos analyses vos
éclairages et vos propositions sur la
question des propositions il y en at il
qui aurait été occulté qui ont été
écoutés occulté et que vous aurait
souhaité être mises en oeuvre
enfin vous avez évoqué à demi-mot votre
regret sur le mode de gouvernance choisi
par notre pays
pouvez vous nous éclairer s'il vous
plaît et que préconisez vous pour
l'avenir je vous remercie
merci enfin je sting inez merci
président moi j'ai qu'une seule question
ça va être très rapide
le conseil scientifique comporte un
pédiatre mais pas de gériatres alors
même que le virus est vous l'avez
souligné vise essentiellement les
personnes âgées ne recule pas jouer un
rôle important au sein de votre conseil
et n'est ce pas dommageable merci merci
je n'ai plus de réponses concernant
l'îlot dentition et le dépistage le
dépistage et l'évaluation des différents
tests dîner réponses n'ont pas été
complète c'est par écrit qu'elles seront
formulées on vous le demande
merci un quart d'heure professeurs pour
répondre globalement à l'ensemble de ces
questions alors sur les les tests de
dépistage puisque c'est un élément
important peut-être qu'il faut qu'on sur
lequel vous soyez pleinement corps enfin
je pense que von linne à vous vous avez
bien briefé là dessus il ya toute une
discussion actuelle sur finalement la
halle et la possibilité d'avoir des
tests à partir de prélèvement salivaire
1 qui permettrait d'avoir une stratégie
plus plus simple les données que nous
avons venant de ce qui a été évalué en
guyane et en région parisienne montrent
qu'en fait à partir d'un prélèvement
salivaire
on a une très bonne spécificités et une
sensibilité de l'ordre de 80% ce qui
suffit c'est à dire que les prélèvement
salivaire seront mis en place
très probablement la dc tout à fait fin
septembre ou début octobre
ce qui quand elle est plus facile moi
j'ai eu trois prélèvements
naso-pharyngés c'est vrai que le
troisième c'est ça dure pas longtemps
m'enfin ça vous titille un peu c'est pas
agréable et c'est donc tout ce qui peut
faciliter le tester une fois quand elle
près de mons à l'hiver caisse contest
est ce contest avec eux des les
techniques actuelles de rt pcr les
grandes plateformes je reviens pas là
dessus vous êtes vous avez été bien
briefé ou est ce qu'on peut avoir des
résultats de tests rapides c'est-à-dire
avec la capacité d'avoir un résultat en
un quart d'heure ou en une heure selon
les selon les possibilités
ces tests existent ils sont ils sont ce
sont des machines fermé jeu
je donne souvent l'exemple comme une
machine à expresso qu'on a chez soi
c'est à peu près de cette taille là et
ça vous permet de mettre le prélèvement
et puis ensuite on laisse la machine
toute seule elle est ferme elle est dans
un blog fermé il n'y a pas besoin de
beaucoup texte du tout technicien et ça
vous donne de réponses en un quart
d'heure en heure
mais attention ça ne donne que en en une
heure
si elle donne résultant en un quart
d'heure ça ne donne le résultat que sur
quatre tests
voyez la différence par rapport aux
grandes plate forme qui sont capables de
faire des centaines et des centaines de
tests c'est à dire que si on devait
passer sur ces tests rapides qui ont un
intérêt parce que je pense que ça ça
concrétise la vision du virus par par
nos citoyens c'est là c'est quelque
chose d'un peu invisible mais ça
concrétise 7e mais à ce moment là il
faudrait de nouveaux commander des
machines individuel chacun vers les
limites
j'exagère mais dans beaucoup de lieux de
santé et avoir beaucoup de machines à
expresso
donc c'est un modèle qui est
complètement différent du modèle des
grandes plateformes et des laboratoires
tel qu'il est conçu actuellement
enfin dernier point est ce que ce haut
lieu d'avoir des techniques de biologie
moléculaire
si on va repérer maintenant les
protéines du virus c'est-à-dire des
tests antigénique qui sont en train
également d'être d'être évalués et là
c'est pour l'instant on ne sait pas et
les données de la littérature monde
qu'il faut attendre qu'on aura peut-être
cet instant tigenix vers la mi-octobre
j'en sais rien work in progress
mais que ce que ce n'est que ce n'est
pas l'instant donc distinguons bien le
prélèvement salivaire qui va être
opérationnel dès début octobre
les tests rapides qui seront
opérationnels et qui peuvent être
intéressants vous imaginez dans un ehpad
par exemple un que chaque ehpad et ce
type 2 et ce type de petites machines
avec soi mais qui ne répondent pas à un
dépistage de masse tels que tel qu'on
l'a tel qu'on l'a réalisé alors il y
avait une autre question sur les tests
qui étaient qui était plutôt la
stratégie des tests
ça a été la même chose enfin que le
conseil scientifique
quand on est arrivé début mars moi j'ai
demandé on est capable de faire combien
de tests en france on était garde de
faire trois mille tests les allemands ce
moment là étaient autour de parts par
jour on était à trois mille tonnes par
jour et les allemands étaient plutôt
autour de noms à trois vitesses par
semaine pendant et les allemands étaient
plutôt autour de 60 milles donc je veux
dire que j'étais totalement persuadé
l'ensemble du conseil scientifique on
l'a inscrit d'ailleurs j'ai déjà envoyé
ce qu'on avait écrit que la stratégie de
tester de façon importante était la
seule stratégie avec une stratégie de
qui auraient pu être utilisés qui était
trop dépassé compte tenu du nombre de
cas supposer qu'on avait début mars mais
que l'on n'avait pas les tests pour le
faire donc on peut toujours dire que il
sait ce qu'il faut faire si on n'a pas
les tests pour le faire alors
reconnaissez aussi con sens inverse
sinde réussit quand même là actuellement
on tourne à 1 million un million cent de
tests par semaine avec une double vision
une test à visée diagnostique chez les
personnes qui ont des symptômes ou qui
ont été en contact
et puis cette large utilisation de test
à viser plutôt santé publique de
dépistage qui est on est on voit bien
que l'on les jeunes d'ailleurs se sont
emparés de ce dit non quand même
impressionnant d'accès alors et tout
fonctionne très bien je vous dis pas le
contraire il ya des délais en
particulier en région parisienne qui
sont encore trop long inversement
province ya des endroits où ça se passe
très bien il faut aussi bon et et en
région parisienne là il ya une stratégie
qui va être mieux défini de bien séparer
ce qui est le test de diagnostic du test
de dépistage
on est finalement les tests sont
victimes de leur de leur succès dans une
certaine mesure et on tourne et on
tourne on est on est en terme
quantitatif on est on est supérieurs je
crois en ce moment à l'allemagne prime
est donc en termes de tests réalisés par
semaine
faut-il encore que ça soit bien adapté
mais il y a une
une fois de plus comme je l'exprimé tout
à l'heure il ya une jeunesse qui a
trouvé son mode de fonctionnement en
partie en tout cas en prenant peu de
précautions je dis pas tous hein et en
ce feu et on est en ayant en comprenant
qu'ils applaudissent et en ayant une
stratégie d'utilisation déteste quand
elle veut revenir et avoir un contact
avec les plus anciens
donc c'est une nouvelle définition donc
les tests c'était la même stratégie
c'est à dire qu'on a reconnu que le
nombre de tests étaient on les avait pas
que de toute façon à ce moment-là début
mars la situation il fallait je veux
dire on aurait tous les tests du monde
c'est trop tard compte tenu du nombre du
nombre de la stratégie de tester tracé
isolée elle était trop c'était fini 1 il
fallait confiné et en russie lisait les
tests au moment où finalement les tester
tester tracé isolé c'est quand on sort
du confinement ou qu'on arrive à mettre
un nombre de patients de personnes
infectées qui est à un niveau
relativement bas dès que ça monte de
façon trop importante et et là on est
dans cette zone là en ce moment dans
certaines régions de france
on voit bien que la stratégie test être
assez isolée peut être déjà très vite
dépassés sur les tests voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire la communication j'y
reviens pas je pense qu'on avait répondu
le
la virulence oui alors il ya une
question sur la virulence qui est que
commet une épidémie de ce type se
termine
est-ce qu'il faut attendre et
probablement on a dit non à des nuances
un ici je parle de simon était à côté de
moi
est-ce qu'il faut attendre vraiment
d'avoir 50% ou 60% d'immunité en
population pour qu'elle s'arrête
simon le pense je pense en grande partie
moi je suis plus nuancé et je pense que
ce chiffre de 50 60 % qui est
atteignable à on a un exemple
extraordinaire qui est le porte avions
charles de gaulle ou dans une population
jeune ils ont atteint cette seconde que
c'est vraiment atteignable cette
immunité de population ils l'ont atteint
est-ce qu'il ya besoin au niveau
national d'atteindre ce niveau là pour
que l'épidémie progressivement baisse
c'est une vraie question je n'ai pas la
réponse personnellement c'est pas
forcément la virulence du virus et c'est
aussi la relation entre le virus et la
réaction immunitaire qu'il a en face de
lui sur sur le touch qu'est ce que j'ai
noté d'autres comme question daniel tu
avais pas des choses oui elle a pas de
gériatrie celle ci fait une très bonne
en bas alors c'est vrai on n'avait pas
de gériatres bon johnny a eu beaucoup de
liens avec les gériatres bordelais on
les a beaucoup écouté c'est à dire qu'on
a gelé peut-être pas suffisamment dit au
début on a ce quelques grandes sociétés
savantes ou ou et en particulier les
gériatres on a eu de nombreuses réunions
avec eux ils nous ont fait une série de
propositions dont on a tenu compte et
qui viennent qui venait de la société
française de gérontologie
mais compte tenu de ce qui a été évoqué
même d'ici peut-être d'ailleurs le 30
octobre il n'est pas exclu qu'on fasse
deux trois propositions de nouveaux
entrants qui nous manque et parmi ceux
ci je pense qu un gériatre serait une
priorité
e la gouvernance daniel tu veux dire un
tout petit mot parce que c'est vrai
qu'on a soulevé ce problème de
gouvernance et qu'on n'a pas eu
forcément toutes les réponses
daniel je veux dire un petit mot cercle
le terme gouvernance c'est tellement
large que j'ai voyagé j'ai du mal à
identifier ceux d'antan se sait ce dont
on discute peut-être quelques éléments
jean-françois effectivement sur les
moyens et un juge la parole je de la
gare peut-être pour pourrait caler aussi
la question de david assouline circuit
effectivement la question de la
construction d'une stratégie après une
réalité et on voit bien que sur ce
séquençage tester tracé isoler la
cohérence d'ensemble est difficile à
construire dans la réalité on était
partis initialement plutôt si vous avez
lu ces avis là c'est à vie un petit peu
stratégique sur l'idée que des moyens
spécifiques et même assez nombreux vous
vous souvenez qu'il ya eu aussi des
débats même des polémiques sur la
terminologie des brigades des équipes
mobiles etc qui doivent être déployés
localement
bon c'est pas les choix qui ont été
faits on allait fed a été faits
collectivement nationalement des choix
d'une nature un peu différente et qui
facilite pas nécessairement la cohérence
jusqu'à l' isolement et donc d'une
certaine manière on se retrouve aussi
dans cette situation où l'ensemble est
pas consolidée et donc du coup nécessite
un des formes de consolidation
progressive aux différents aux
différents étages d'une certaine manière
ça illustre à mon sens en tout cas ça
illustre cette difficulté à mettre en
oeuvre des logiques de santé publique et
des acteurs de santé publique et du coup
la nécessité de se rabattre sur des
acteurs sur le type des acteurs de santé
des acteurs de soins qui peuvent remplir
évidemment des fonctions de santé
publique
mais non c'est pas la vocation première
mais les caisses primaires d'assurance
maladie ni sans doute d'autres d'autres
acteurs de santé s'interrogent aussi sur
les moyens de santé publique a man
données sont susceptibles d'être
mobilisées dans ce type 2
de situation et je vais te répondre
jean-françois peut-être sur les moyens
on a pu disposer
je reprends quand même sur sasp et la
sueur tester préciser parce que c'est
une très bonne question est ce qu'on
s'est donné les moyens
est ce que le gouvernement s'est donné
les moyens de ses ambitions
c'est ça votre question est très
clairement nous on avait évoqué un autre
schéma de construction avec une place
peut être probablement plus importante
sur les médecins généralistes et avec
eux ce qui a été construit dans un
certain nombre d'autres pays des
brigades a le mot avait fait à l'époque
un peu un peu tanguay entre guillemets
mais c'est ce qui s'est passé encore et
c'est ce qui s'est passé y compris en
allemagne également hélas le système
français s'est appuyé sur le système
déjà existant autour de la cnam et de
repérage de ddd qu'à contacter et des
cas positifs à partir de là clame avec
le tableau vous donner il est vraiment
très négatif
il ya des gens qui sont contactés il y a
et on a des chiffres le dernier les
tables j'ai vu donc b c'est un modèle
qui et je dirai d'ordre plutôt
administratif avec eux avec une très
bonne volonté une construction et qui
était à sortir très vite nous avions
évoqué nous de s'appuyer sur plus sur
des sur les le milieu associatif sur le
bio sur le milieu des assistantes
sociales
sur le million région qui pouvait créer
sur le médecin et sur le modèle des
médecins généralistes bon voilà on est
après c'est la construction de ça c'est
quand même pas si facile vous avez vu
que l'on a sur un des points testés
tracé isolé on a voulu peut prendre la
parole sur l' isolement pour revenir à
et cadres est bien ce qu est l isolement
un à la fois le réduire sur cette
période de sept jours
mais aussi dire que dès qu'on a une
suspicion ou qu'on a à k contact sans
attendre le résultat du test on doit
s'isoler
c'est les choses assez simples mais mais
qu'il faut rappeler et donc on est là en
effet dans une situation où le pool
maillon le maillot qu'ils ont
peu faible c'est le thrace le traçage et
la capacité à mobiliser
l'un ensemble de troupes vous avez vu
que le premier ministre a décidé de
donner des moyens supplémentaires à la
cnam
avec 2000 personnes à recruter et ça se
recrutent pas du jour bon pour pour
apporter une amélioration aux délais de
tracing voilà merci juste juste une
précision oui parce que je je ne veux
pas être négatif bonjour je souhaite que
tout se passe bien mais un moment je
n'ai aucun cas en ce moment il ya
beaucoup de cas dans nos entourages - tu
un rapport avant on en a beaucoup je
n'ai aucun retour de quelqu'un qui a été
appelé après avoir été testé positif
aucun sur les 7 de la fête dont je vous
parle
sept ont été contaminées identifié aucun
a été appelé il y avait des cas où les
deux étaient négatifs mais ensuite ils
l'ont attrapé un an
il y en a un qui était positif l'on ne
savait pas qu'il était positif puisque
le test n'était pas arrivé donc à
contaminer bon personne n'a été après
non plus pour proposer un isolement
voire même jeu qu'on a des cas a appelé
la sécurité aux iem pour dire j'ai
besoin d'un isolement parce que si je
retourne chez mes parents je vais les
contaminer si ma femme retourne chez ses
parents à contaminer des personnes âgées
donc on a on n'a pas de solution il nous
faut un truc pour pas dormir à la rue si
on veut s'isoler
on ne sait même pas de quoi vous me
parlez de trion c'est oui donc moi je ne
peux pas nuancé ce qui se passe puisque
100% des cas que je connais ses volontés
ont choisi sur les allemands n'ont pas
été appelé c'est votre expérience sur ce
qu'elle a je me rappelle ce qui se passe
à bordeaux par exemple
au tracé au tester tracé est isolé avec
la grosse plateforme la grande
plateforme centrale à la métropole qui
était dépassé par son succès et donc il
ya une articulation de moyens qui sont
disponibles avec la réorganisation au
moins provisoire de l'accès aux tests et
c'est ce qu'on appelle la priorisation
qui je crois est est en train de
commencer à porter ses fruits même si le
rendu des résultats à un moment avait pu
être prolongé
voilà c'est une articulation qui est
offerte à l'invitation des territoires
quand je dis territoire c'est un peu
outrancier puisque ici je ne parle que
de la cité et que de la métropole mais
dans lesquels différents acteurs peuvent
travailler ensemble pour être capable de
s'adapter de manière réactive pour des
activités cohérente même si elles sont
distinctes en l'occurrence le suivi des
patients et l activité de traçage ainsi
merci
hier des noms ne s'en étaient positifs
et des nombres de rappeler vous devrait
pouvoir réponse peut être fait et je
crois que c'est la gestion n'est pas de
votre responsabilité
je voudrais juste une information je
sors un peu du sujet merci il ya des
endroits d'autres collègues pourrait
témoigner ou effectivement ça s'est
correctement passée rassurons nos
concitoyens donc par écrit vous pourrez
monsieur le professeur merci davance
répondre avec plus de précision à un
certain nombre de questions de nos
collègues mais je crois que cette
audition a été riche
preuve en est le nombre de questions il
nous faut la terminer et vous encourager
dans cet exercice fort difficile à la
fois d'avoir un affichage fiq solide qui
soit derrière suivie d'une décision
politique
[Musique]
fonctionnel et qui souhaite ensuite
accepté sur le plan sociétal
voilà donc donc cet exercice là le sénat
aura un certain nombre de préconisations
me semble-t-il à faire compte tenu du
nombre d'auditions que nous avons déjà
réalisé en tout cas merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
merci mes chers collègues et prend des
vous à 15 heures